My new book, Atlas of Unidentified Flying Objects, is now available to pre-order wherever books are sold, including Amazon, Barnes and Noble and Waterstones. Explore the UFO phenomenon through 34 cases from throughout the world, with accompanying pictures and maps in a beautiful hardback edition or download for your Kindle. Links available in the podcast description below. Hi everyone and welcome back to That UFO Podcast. As always, my name is Andy and this is part two of your Omnibus on The Authors. Folks who I have interviewed, who have written some sensational books in and around the topic of UFOs, of course. And this one's coming out to you with what I feel are some potential hidden gems that I've had over the years going back to 2022 and 2023. And again, it really surprises me how long ago some of these interviews were. For me, they seem like they happened last year. But all of them are 22 and 23. You're going to hear Kevin Randall discussing his book, Levelland, on the events of November 1957 in West Texas. A great interview from back in the day, I think that was 2022. Jeffrey Kripal, that's from 2023, talking UFOs and the impossible, talking about thinking impossibly and his work creating the archives of the impossible. A lot of impossible in there, but very much an enjoyable interview. And then one that I really feel went under the radar, mainly because of when it was released. So I recorded with Dr. Paul Thigpen on his book, Extra-terrestrial Intelligence and the Catholic Faith. I recorded this one, I think it was either Christmas Eve or the day after Christmas 2023. And it was released between Christmas and New Year. It's that time of year where people can take a bit of a break, especially from podcasting. You release some omnibus episodes like this one. But yeah, I really enjoyed the interview and hear some differing takes from a religious aspect, which I know is always a popular topic. Lots of great guests coming up in the next couple of weeks for fresh content, folks. But in the meantime, please enjoy The Authors Part 2. And don't forget, you can also check out my new book available for pre-order right now, as we record this in June 2025, Atlas of Unidentified Flying Objects. The genius link is in the description for the podcast. If you can pre-order, thank you so, so much. But anyway, over to the guests. Podcast, my name is Andy and delighted to welcome on to the show with me today, retired US. Air Force, author of over 100 books and UFO investigator, Kevin Randall. Kevin, welcome to the podcast.
Well, thank you very much, but I do need to make one quick correction. I'm retired Army officer.
Ah, my bad. Do you know what?
Not really, not really, because I did spend some time in the Air Force as well.
So do you know what it is when I've seen USAF? I think I just automatically go into that on the book. But yes, thank you for correcting me, Hal. And I think I get away with it being British as well, don't I? That we're not as au fait with the American military as perhaps someone on the other side of the pond would be. But Kevin, you've got quite an interesting background, let alone what you've been involved in over the decades in terms of UFOs. What's your journey been like into ufology and UFOs? Was it something you had an interest in as a child or was it something that came much later?
Well, I always blame my mother for my interest. She was a fan of science fiction, which is about alien visitation and interstellar flight and alien civilizations and that sort of thing. And when I was a youngster, and this dates me, she took me to the movie Earth vs. the Flying Saucers. And that kind of sparked my interest because, of course, flying saucers were talking about alien civilizations and interstellar flight and alien visitation. So it's sort of the same thing, moving it from the realm of science fiction into the realm of reality. So that kind of sparked my interest. Back in the 1960s, when I got very interested in UFOs, the attitude was that, well, we just, they're just blobs of light in the distance. They're indistinct objects. They're things that can't really be identified because of those sorts of problems. And a friend of mine's mother had had a UFO sighting, flying saucer sighting. So I asked him if I could meet with her, and she, of course, agreed. And the only question I really wanted to answer was, was it a distinct object? And she said it was an object hovering about 200 feet over the barn. They lived on a ranch in South Dakota, if I remember correctly. And she said it had very distinct edges, very, very sharp, crisp edges. So it wasn't something seen in the distance. It wasn't a blob of light. It was a structured craft she had seen. And that sort of sparked my investigative nature as well, getting the answers for myself. And that, of course, has carried on through since that time. I've worked on enough, a lot of cases and an awful lot of in-field work, chased down an awful lot of sightings and interviewed an awful lot of witnesses to UFOs and that sort of thing. My military career, of course, spans decades as well. I started out as a helicopter pilot. I learned that the Army, the United States Army, was training high school graduates as helicopter pilots. And so I joined the Army to learn to become a helicopter pilot and was sent to Vietnam as a pilot at 19. Was an aircraft commander, spent a tour in Vietnam, came back, got out of the Army, went to college, got a degree and took ROTC. Now, the thing is, in the American military, those of us who were high school graduates and went through that program were appointed ward officers. So, we were the lowest ranking officer, but we weren't really commissioned, which made us eligible to take ROTC, the Reserve Officers Training Corps. So, while I was in college, I took the last two years of college in ROTC and was commissioned as an officer in the Air Force. So, I spent a number of years in the Air Forces in a number of different roles, mainly as an intelligence officer for them in a number of different places. Got out of the Army after 9-11, I joined the Iowa National Guard, which is an Army unit, as an intelligence officer, and eventually retired from that as a lieutenant colonel, having spent a tour in Iraq. So, I applied all that knowledge I gained as an intelligence officer to the investigations that I conducted specifically with Roswell. I was invited into the Roswell case by the Center for UFO Studies because they knew of my military background, and a lot of the witnesses that we would be talking to had military backgrounds or retired military officers. And they thought I'd be able to relate with them more and understand the lingo a little bit better than someone who had not served in the military. So, that kind of was the genesis of my invitation into the Roswell case with Don Schmidt. And we spent a great deal of time in Roswell, New Mexico, talking to witnesses, ferreting out new witnesses, and getting recordings, both video and audio recordings of a large number of witnesses, talked to some witnesses. I was the only one who talked to a couple of the witnesses, the way things worked out. Edwin Easley springs to mind, he was a provost marshal in Roswell in 1947. Provost marshal being like the chief of police on the air base, he was responsible for security and that sort of thing. And I talked to him a number of times. And the one thing that sticks in my mind talking to him, and some of it was recorded and some of it was not given the circumstances. But I was talking to him about the case, and I said, are we following the right path? And he said, what do you mean? And I said, well, we think it's extraterrestrial. And he said, let me put it this way, it's not the wrong path. So in essence, confirm the extraterrestrial nature of the Roswell case. And we had a number of officers, high-ranking officers in Roswell in 1947, confirmed that sort of an event, the single exception being one of the big guy named Barrelclaw, who is a retired colonel. And he said, no, nothing like that happened. He's the only member of General Ramey's staff that we were, Colonel Ramey, I'm sorry, Colonel Blanchard's staff, that we were able to talk to, who denied anything happened. All the others that we talked to said, yeah, it was something extraterrestrial. And this goes from the highest-ranking officers on the base down to the lowest-ranking enlisted soldiers on the base, that we were able to talk to privates and corporals and buck sergeants who said essentially the same thing. So we had a wide range of that sort of thing. So that kind of gives you a background of my interest in UFOs. And from there, of course, it expanded. And I was doing a number of books. I've been writing UFO articles. And I say I went to college on what I called the Saga Scholarship. Saga was a men's magazine, not like Playboy or Penthouse, but it just was articles that catered to men. And there might be a scantily clad picture of a woman in a magazine once in a while, but it really didn't, that wasn't the focus. It was the articles geared toward men. And they paid enough money. I was able to write an article of semester for the magazine and get paid for it, and that paid my tuition except for $10. So I say I went to college on the Saga scholarship. And I collected the magazine articles into a book later on in 1989 and added some new material to that. And then the second UFO book I did was on Roswell. And from there, it's expanded out. I've done 25 or 28 UFO books. So I've done a lot of research into it, and I understand what's going on in the world of UFOs.
That's an incredible, thanks for the backstory, because it's a wonderful history. You've put into just a couple of minutes. They are almost six or seven decades. After all that time, what is still driving you to write about the subject of UFOs? Because there's so many in this topic in a far shorter time, become disillusioned or they fall out of love with it. But you've kept that passion to keep writing even now?
One of my goals in life was to be a writer. And you mentioned I've published, I lost count of 125 books. It's somewhere over that number. But it's science fiction, it's action adventure and it's UFOs. And so I've always wanted to be a writer. So this is one way I could express my opinions that way. But the subject always fascinated me as well. And I had a good friend, Wilson Bob Tucker, and those who are into science fiction and science fiction conventions would know Bob Tucker. Wrote a number of science fiction books, really good science fiction books, but never got the kind of publicity that Isaac Asimov or Ray Bradbury got, but an incredible writer. And with that sort of thing going on, we wanted to, you know, well, the point was that at one point, talking to Bob Tucker is that he explained that he was retired from writing. And as a much younger person, I couldn't understand that, why you would retire from writing. And here I am now at an age commensurate with what he was at the time. And I'm still writing. I have a book due to Philip Mantle called Understanding Roswell. Actually, it was due a number of weeks ago. I'm a little late on it. But it's almost finished now and will be in time for the 75th anniversary. But it's just sort of a drive. I just feel the urge to continue writing. And because in the last year or so, actually the last six months, I've had to do three UFO books. I've been requested to do the books. The Levelland Sighting, which we'll talk about, I guess a little later, is what I think of as the second most important UFO sighting. Because of the number of people involved in the interactions with the environment. But it's just a story that I wanted to tell. And I think that's the whole point. I continue to want to tell the story. So I just can't see myself retiring. I can see myself slowing down. And for publishing fewer books, but I just can't see a retirement from. So it's kind of the desire to tell the stories, to engage people in things that interest me and continue the research into the UFO phenomenon until we get a definitive answer.
Well, that passion and drive is taking you to write about Levelland, which we're of course going to talk about. And I'd like to do that now. The events of Levelland, West Texas, I believe, it was November 1957. Can you tell us a little bit, if you remember, when you first heard about this particular event?
It's always been an interest of mine because of the nature of the sightings. It was people at a number of different locations, independently reporting to the sheriff. This thing had come close to the ground or landed on the ground near the car, installed the engine and put out the headlights and that sort of thing. And looking at that whole group of sightings in November of 1957. So I've been interested in it for a long time. It was only recently that I began to understand the importance of it. A fellow named Don Berlinson, who lives in Roswell. Roswell being three hours by car from Levelland. Levelland, for those of you who want to look on a map, is right near Lubbock, Texas, in the Panhandle of Texas. So if you can't find Levelland, just go a little bit west of Lubbock, and that's where Levelland is. Had interviewed the widow of the sheriff back around the year 2000. And she told him some things that were very interesting to me and kind of inspired me to look a little bit deeper into it. One of the things I discovered is if you look at the Air Force file, the Project Lubbock file on Levelland, they interview the sheriff whose name is Weir Clem, a name I positively hate. I wish it was something like Tom Collins or Jim Beam for that matter, or James Bond, some good name, not Weir Clem. But he had told the Air Force according to their file, well, he eventually was interested enough because there had been enough sightings been reported to him that they were going to go out and look for it. And he saw the object in the distance. He said it was just to streak a light in sight for two seconds. That's what it says in the Air Force file. I found documentation printed in newspapers prior to the Air Force investigation, where he was talking about seeing a oval-shaped object that was bright red. And then later on, a fellow named Don Berliner, yes, there's a lot of dons in this conversation. Don Berliner in the mid-1970s talked to the sheriff, talked to Sheriff Clem. And Clem again said that he had seen the object. So we've got him saying it prior to the Air Force investigation and then somewhat later after the Air Force had written down what he had to say. The other thing that came out, and we're back to Don Berliner now, he learned that the mechanic for the sheriff's department was still alive in 2000 and interviewed him and said that the sheriff had come into the shop and wanted his car checked out the next day. The only reason the sheriff would have had his car checked out the next day is if he'd gotten close enough to the object that it stalled it. So we have documentation saying get close enough to it to see an object. Then we have information that suggests his car was stalled. Now, what makes this even more important in some of the other sightings of in that short time frame of two and a half hours in Levelland, is that he was in a mini convoy. He was in one of the sheriff's department car with a deputy. Behind him was a state police car. I think then it was called the Texas Department of Public Safety. That's what it was when I lived there in the 1960s, and I think it was that in 1957. So now you have state police involved. And behind them was a third car with Air Force officers in it. This tells me that they got close enough that their cars were stalled. And that tells me the Air Force officers observed the phenomenon of the car engines being stalled and the bright red glowing object being close enough that they could see what it was. But there's nothing in the Air Force file that talks about an investigation or interrogation of the Air Force officers involved. All we have are six different interviews conducted two or three days later by a staff sergeant that came down from Colorado Springs and interviewed the sheriff, a couple of the witnesses and let it go at that. Didn't do a comprehensive investigation. That was it. Now, years later, many years later, I was able to find the names of many, many people who were involved based not only on what the Air Force report said, the Air Force documents say, but the newspaper files that we could go through. And we'd find witnesses in there that were interviewed. The APRO Bulletin, the Aerial Phenomenon Research Organization, which was a civilian organization, was involved in the investigation in 1957, as was the National Investigations Committee on Aerial Phenomena, which is also a civilian organization based on Washington, DC. They had one of their investigators out there talking to people. So looking at all these documents created at that time, we were able to find the names of many, many other people who were involved. The sheriff said that he had received dozens of phone calls about this, which suggests additional witnesses as well. So it's a case with many, many witnesses at independent locations reporting the same phenomenon. The sheriff also, at least according to the wife, the widow, said that there had been landing traces on a ranch outside of town. I think it was north of town. Berlinson went there and interviewed the widow of the rancher, but the rancher's daughter as well. And the rancher and the daughter went out and saw the burned area, as did the sheriff. So now we have landing traces on the ground, which had they been researched properly in 1957, might have presented us with some very interesting data. We know that it interacted with the environment by stalling the car engines and filling radios with static and putting out the headlights. And when the object left, left and the cars could be restarted, and it was only one case where the guy said the car started spontaneously, but the cars could be started. So they stopped working at the close approach of the UFO and began working again when the UFO was gone. So we've got an interaction with the environment and we have many independent witnesses. Think of the data we could have collected at that time, had NICAP not got involved with the Air Force in an argument over the number of witnesses. So the Air Force successfully diverted the conversation from what happened to how many witnesses there really were.
Now, am I right and correct me here that Dr. Alan Hynek was involved, and this was before Blue Book was official. It was Project Sign. He was a consultant at the time, and he was involved in explaining the event as being prosaic. But if I'm correct, he wasn't actually involved in the investigation and had only seen that Air Force report.
Hynek was not involved directly with the Levelland case. Hynek came on board as a scientific consultant to, I think, Project Sign, as you said, which was in 1948. And he continued in that mission almost through the end of Project Blue Book, the 22 years from Sign to Grudge to Blue Book. But he had nothing really to do with Levelland. The investigator, the official investigator was a staff sergeant, Norman Barth, who came out of an air intelligence service squadron in Colorado Springs and flew down to Reese Air Force Base, Reese Air Force Base being in Lubbock. And then it's just a short drive to Levelland from there. So they didn't spend a lot of money on the investigation. But the official conclusion, which is still registered in the Project Blue Book files today in the Master Index, it was created, is it was Ball Lightning. Well, anybody who knows anything about Ball Lightning knows that there's still an argument about whether there is such a thing as Ball Lightning. But more importantly, the descriptions of it is something that's very small, 18 inches, two feet in diameter and very short live, a matter of seconds. So it's a glowing ball of blue fire, so to speak, that winks out of existence rapidly. We're talking about sightings of something was bright red for the most part, Pedro Saucido, who is the first person to call the Levelland Sheriff, at I think 1030 that night on November 2nd, said it was a brightly glowing blue object that landed close to his truck, stalled the truck, he was so frightened he dived out of the truck. The passenger was even more petrified and sat in the passenger's seat while the object sat on the ground and then it turned to a bright, glowing red and it took off and then the truck could be restarted. So we have the descriptions of the color changes, but for the most part, people were talking about a bright red object on the ground that was in sight for minutes. The whole series of sightings in Levelland took place over about two, two and a half hours on November 2nd into the morning of November 3rd. I think one of the witnesses talked about sitting there watching it for 15 minutes. Another said he watched it for five minutes. So no matter how you look at it, ball lightning is not a credible answer for what happened in Roswell. I'm sorry, in Levelland. Roswell just pops into my mind because I'm finished the book on Roswell now.
Well, I was going to ask on that, is there anything particularly special about Levelland in your research, in your investigations, that this event happened here? Was there anything nearby or?
Nothing. With Roswell, you can talk about the Atomic Strike Force being based at Roswell. And you can look at New Mexico where not that far from Roswell, we're firing rockets into the atmosphere higher than ever before. And now, of course, we've gone to the moon. But if you're interstellar race, if you're a space traveling race and you find a civilization that's on the verge of taking its first steps into space and they have atomic weapons, you're going to be concerned about those people. But Levelland, no, there's nothing special about it other than it's three hours from Roswell. Now, an hour or so after the sightings ended in Levelland, there were sightings at the White Sands Missile Range by military police. The Air Force wrote those off as being hysteria and misidentification of the moon because of the Levelland sightings. But the first sightings were by a couple of MPs within hours of the sightings in Levelland. They talked about something that came down close to the ground. They could see it silhouetted against the mountains behind the object. So clearly, it wasn't the moon, it wasn't Venus, as the Air Force claimed. It was something much closer and something was much closer to the ground. And the Air Force dismissed it and said, well, the MPs were very young, they were 20, 21 years old. And they got caught up in the hysteria of the time. And I'm thinking, no, they couldn't have been caught up in the hysteria of the time because there wasn't social media. There wasn't immediate access to this information about the sightings in Levelland as they were happening, as we'd have today. You'd have everybody on their cell phones saying, geez, you know, come out here, look what's going on. It didn't get reported until the next morning. So they had they had no knowledge of this. They couldn't been caught up in the hysteria. I talked to one of the MPs. And he just he told me exactly what they'd seen. And of course, that's recorded in the book, Levelland. But the thing that really annoyed me was the dismissal of them saying, well, they were poorly trained and they were young men and they just really didn't know what was going on. And I'm thinking, yeah, they're 20, 21 years old. I think I think Glenn Toy, who was the one I talked to, I think he was 21 in 1957. And I'm thinking, I'm in Vietnam as a helicopter pilot and an aircraft commander at 19. I think George HW. Bush was a pilot in the Navy at 19 during the Second World War. So a great deal of responsibility is placed on the shoulders of very young individuals. And there's not a second thought about that. The things always cracked me up. We had one of the helicopter pilots in the flights. We called him Papa because he was the oldest pilot flying with us. He was 23. And so we're thinking, the oldest guy is 23. So we were all 20, 21, 22 years old. I think I was the youngest pilot in the unit at the time. But the dismissal of the testimony simply because they were young men is just preposterous. And that's kind of the attitude of the Air Force. What can we do to dismiss the cases or make it look like it's something that it's not? And we see that time after time after time when you look at the Air Force files and you go through the files and you say, you know, this sighting really isn't identified as ball lightning or Venus coming down and landing 150 feet away from the guys in the jeep on White Sands. So we take a look at all of that sort of thing.
Now, like you say, you've got multiple sightings happening over hours and over quite a large space as well. That's always a good thing when it comes to data. And for a researcher and an investigator, you can actually say, well, they saw it here and they saw it here. Then they saw this over here as well. Is that something that you have managed to see that there could be any prosaic explanation for? Is there something you've looked at and thought, well, possibly it could be this, but ultimately you're obviously leaning towards some more ET explanation.
With Levelland, you've got it interacting with the environment, stalling the car engines. So what kind of natural phenomenon or mechanism do we have in 1957 that would do that? In my research, I found that the Japanese during the Second World War were experimenting with magnetic effects and seeing if they could stop an engine with a magnetic ray, if they could get close enough to it, because if you can knock the other guy's fighter planes out of the sky with a magnetic ray from a distance your way ahead, I think they managed to get it to work up to 10 feet. They just could not get beyond, I guess, the universe square a lot, which is the farther away you get, you reduce it by a square as opposed to doubling it. But they couldn't get beyond that. So we know of no mechanism that we have, and I don't think there's anything in the technology today that we have that would do that. And it would be interesting to say, well, you know, it was just something wrong with the car. In fact, the Air Force pulled that out in Levelland. Pedro Saucido had his truck prepared, I think the day before the sightings. And after the sightings, it took it back in to have it looked at, and they found a piece of metal in the rotor, which could have shorted out the, in the distributor, could have shorted out the firing of the spark plugs. But then you have to ask yourself, well, why did it only manifest itself once? And why only when this object was close by and once the object was gone, well, then I can start my truck again. And then you have all the others that report the same thing. So we know of no mechanism. The Air Force, I think, you mentioned Hynek, and I think Hynek at once, once had said about the Levelland sightings, well, you can, you can eliminate the Pedro C. Cito sighting. And I think, well, no, you really can't. He said the other one would be a coincidence. But when you get the two coincidences, then you're moving it pretty much outside the realm of coincidence. And then when we begin talking about people identified at 13 separate locations at least that we know of, then you've moved it way beyond coincidence. So there is no mechanism that explains the sightings in terrestrial fashion. And I think that's an important point with the Levelland sightings is we have no terrestrial explanation that accounts for all the reported malfunctions of vehicles and the sightings of the object. I mean, it's a glowing red. I think Saucido called it a torpedo shaped. Other people's called it egg shaped. And I'm thinking, you know, that's probably a matter of perspective where you were when you saw the object, how you looked at it. If you look at, you know, like a tanker truck for straight on, it looks like a big cigar shaped object. But if you look at it from an angle, then you begin to get egg shaped or other looking shapes to it. So it's a matter of perspective, not the craft changing shape, but it's just a matter of perspective. And we have an awful lot of discussion of what it looked like and how long it was visible and what it did when it was on the ground. Now, if we could have coupled it to the landing trace case, then we've got an even greater body of evidence about it. So we had an opportunity there to investigate this case properly. But the Air Force at that time was more interested in explaining cases and keeping the public misinformed about UFOs than it was in actually investigating UFOs. Two or three days later, on November 6th, I think it was a guy named James Stokes was driving from Alamogordo, the Hullman Air Force Base to El Paso, Texas. And if you look at your map, it's what an hour and a half, two hours from Alamogordo to El Paso. You go through a little town called Oro Grande. And as he approached Oro Grande, his radio began to fade out. And it was when it was going on, then his engine sputtered and quit and he pulled over the side of the road. And he's sitting there behind six or seven other cars. And they're watching an H-shaped object as it flies around overhead for a moment. When the object disappeared, of course, he got into his car. And I don't know if he continued on to El Paso and then went home that night. But when he got home to Alamogordo, they called Jim Lorenzen, who was with Corl Lorenzen, the leader of the Aero Phenomenon Research Organization. They were based in Alamogordo at the time. And he went to see them and they noticed he had a slight, like sunburn on half of his face and one of his arms. And if you remember close encounters at the third kind, Richard Dreyfus had that similar problem, much more pronounced from reading it, much more pronounced than what Stokes experienced. But here's another group of sightings with multiple witnesses again and multiple car stories. And another effect of the UFO. And the Air Force spent a lot of time maligning James Stokes, who was an engineer working at Hullman Air Force Base. And his bosses at the base were saying, well, he's an engineer working for us. He spent 20 years in the Navy and he doesn't have a, he wasn't a licensed engineer, but he was doing engineering stuff. And his bosses are saying, yes, he's an engineer. And the Air Force that came in out was, well, we couldn't find a degree for him for Air Force, so we can't trust what he has to say because he's embellishing his resume. He's working as an engineer. Whether he's got a degree or not is irrelevant. He's got a position where he is called an engineer on an Air Force base. So you can see how they tried to belittle the witnesses and reduce their importance and their credibility by smearing their reputations. And you can see in many other cases, them doing the same things with other witnesses, doing everything they can to make the person look like an egotist or somebody who's jumping on the bandwagon or somebody who's not very bright. And you get into the depth of the person and you learn there's a great deal more to them than just the smear thrown out by the Air Force.
Kevin, you read my mind when you brought up the effects, the physical effects of close contact, because that was going to be my next question. So it's interesting you had that, you say sunburn effect, so these objects were clearly within a range or causing some sort of interference that was affecting the human skin. Was there any lasting effects you found out from people that maybe lasted a lot longer into later life? Was there any cancers or rare diseases?
In Levelland, no, the sunburn effect on Stokes faded in a matter of hours. In fact, when the Air Force showed up to investigate a couple of days later, his skin tone had returned to normal. There was no evidence of the reddening of the sunburn effect. There's another story that one of the MPs was not available for the Air Force investigation. I think his name was Will Banks. And the story is he was in the hospital. But what they told the Air Force was that we gave him a three-day pass. And I'm thinking, yeah, we know that there's going to be an investigation. We know the guy is coming down. And now we put him on a three-day pass. Now if you're on a three-day pass, and I know this from my military experience, you have to leave a phone number. You have to be, they have to be able to contact you. So even if the person who granted the three-day pass didn't know the Air Force was coming down to investigate, he would have learned when they got there and he would have been recalled Will Banks, I believe it's Will Banks, to the Holloman Air Force base so he could be interviewed. The other thing is a three-day pass has limitation of how far you can travel. He would have been basically in the local area. The story is from the Lorenzins is he was in the hospital, and he was in the hospital because of the effects, but there was no lasting effects. We move into the realm of the Cash Landrum sighting in 1980, where there were the apparent lasting effects. John Schuchler, I think it is, has done a great deal of work investigating that case. Kirk Collins on his blog has a great deal of information about the Cash Landrum case. If you go to your search engine, you just type in Cash Landrum, I think it'll take you to all the information that's available on this. Philip Glass said that the effects experienced by the two women and the young boy were pre-existing conditions. But it doesn't seem that's quite accurate because it seems that some of the later effects, and I think there may have been some cancer involved in there. I'm not sure because I haven't spent a lot of time investigating that case. But I think there was some cancer effects there and were lasting throughout their lives. There have been cases where people have suffered more debilitating effects than was exhibited in Levelland. So we have a range of those sorts of things. And that's the other thing. There's all these subsets of ufology, and I'm chasing one now where people were trying to take pictures or video with their cell phones of UFOs and the camera failed. Camera worked fine before the UFO was there. Camera worked fine after the UFO was gone, but when they were trying to video the UFO, camera didn't work. Sometimes it gets sound. You can hear the sound. You can hear what they're saying, and you can hear all the sound in the background. But the image of the UFO is gone and that sort of thing. And so I've been looking into those cases. There are quite a few of those where the cameras have failed on that. So that's another kind of side effect of a close approach of the UFO.
One event that I suppose we were just before camera phones became mass-manufactured or even available was the Phoenix Lights, of course. And that's the kind of thing we would have loved to have seen more footage from. There was a huge fallout from the Phoenix Lights event in the mid-90s because so many people in the city saw these lights. They saw what they reported as a huge triangle or V-shape flying overhead. Was there any similar fallout from Levelland where the people of the town were scared? Did they report it? Was there anything that kind of carried on afterwards?
There doesn't seem to be, and I've looked at an awful lot of the newspapers from that time frame and you're looking at it, it seemed to be more of an interest in the subject. There doesn't seem to be anybody really frightened by it. Those who were experienced in their car stalling, they were frightened because they didn't understand what was going on. But for the people in the area around that, in Levelland, in Lubbock, in the West Texas, in the Panhandle, there doesn't seem to be any long lasting fright. Since you brought that up, I wonder if that might be a result of the Lubbock Lights, which was Lubbock, of course, right there in my Levelland. It took place in 1951. They had some experience with these sorts of phenomenon being reported and there's no lasting effect to anybody. I think they looked at it more in the realm of, not this kind of thing again, as opposed to, oh my God, what's happening around here. And I think as we move into our timeframe, when we're all experienced with movies and science fiction of alien visitation and that sort of thing, there's an awful lot of documentaries on UFOs. And I think a lot of people realize, this stuff's been going on, if we count from 1947 for 75 years, if we take it back to the Second World War where the Foo Fighters and the Ghost Rockets in Scandinavia and Northern Europe in 1946, it's been going on even longer. And there's really been no adverse effect. You can point to very few people who were injured by close approaches of UFOs, and that's usually a side effect, not something that is done purposely. We can look at the Thomas Mantell case from January of 1948. He was killed chasing a UFO. I believe now, based on the documentation, we've been able to secure over the years, and I'm at odds with a number of my colleagues in the field. I believe what he saw was a skyhook balloon. And I believe it was launched in Minnesota a day or so earlier. And if you watch the wind patterns, it would have been pretty much where Mantell saw it. And the problem wasn't that the UFO, whatever it might have been, took any action to stop Mantell. But Mantell violated one of the regulations. He climbed too high without benefit of oxygen. And I did some research into both anoxia and hypoxia, which one is the complete lack of oxygen in the blood, and the other was a reduced oxygen in blood, which has all kinds of effects on the brain. And I think at 24,000 feet without supplemental oxygen, the average person has a useful consciousness of about 10 minutes. If you get about 2,000 feet above that, you've got a useful consciousness of about four minutes. And if you get to 29,000 feet, it's like 29 seconds. But the problem is Mantell didn't climb directly to 25,000 feet or whatever. He did it in gradual stages. So he was up, they were circling at about 20,000 feet at one point. And the wingmen with Mantell started to experience, or one of them did start to experience the hypoxia. And they broke off the intercept. And Mantell says, well, I'm going to go to 25,000 feet and circle for 10 minutes. And if I can't get any closer, then I'll break it off. He didn't make it to 25,000 feet. He passed out with the aircraft timed to, trimmed to climb. And at about 30,000 feet, the torque of the engine pulled it over into a power dive and it disintegrated. The aircraft disintegrated about 19,000 feet based on the stresses on the airframe that it was not designed to withstand. So he was, if I am correct, he was killed chasing a skyhook balloon. If my colleagues are correct, he was killed chasing a flying saucer, but the flying saucer, the UFO took no action against him. So no matter what the object was, the result of the aircraft accident was Mantell violation of orders, which said above 14,000 feet you're required to use oxygen. And he didn't, although the aircraft was equipped for oxygen, the oxygen had not been charged and he may not have had his oxygen mask with him because the flight was scheduled to be at 5,000 feet. So there was no need for the oxygen equipment.
I have a couple of colleagues, Dave Partridge and Graham Rendell, who actually want to speak to you. But they are specialists from the UK, especially when it comes to historical UFO cases. Graham's got a fantastic book out about the Foo Fighters that you mentioned of World War II. But I'll pass that information on to you at the end, but they would love to speak to you about that Mantell case as well. What I would like to know, Kevin, is what can these historical events like Levelland, like Roswell that you've got a new book coming out about, you say as well, what can they teach us about the phenomenon today and help us understand what may be happening?
What we're looking at is investigations that took place at the time. So information was gathered at the time, and then we've got subsequent investigations conducted by both military and civilians through the years. So we've gathered a great deal of data. And what we see is an effort to suppress the information by the American government, and I think maybe the British government and other governments around the world to suppress the information. And I know the Air Force, the Australians were going to investigate UFOs based on reading Don Kehoe's book, Flying Saucers from Outer Space, or one of those books. And so the Air Force officers contacted American officers about UFOs, Flying Saucers, and the American's attitude was, oh, there's nothing to it, you can't believe a thing Kehoe says, don't do it. Turns out if you go back and you research Kehoe's book carefully, you see that most of what he printed, although he couldn't name all the sources he had because they were talking to him off the record, so to speak, the information was accurate. You see our Air Force, the US Air Force manipulating the Air Forces in other countries to not do solid investigations. But by going back and studying these cases, we learn an awful lot about not only what was going on, we get some clues about propulsion, we get some clues about other aspects of it. But the thing that's really important, I think, is if you're told repeatedly something is impossible, you probably don't attempt it. But if you realize it is possible and you're not sure how it's done, you begin to try to figure out how to do it yourselves. So if we are blessed with the information that interstellar flight is possible, we see it as impossible given the distances and the technology we possess at the time. We just can't really do it. But if somebody else has figured out how to do it, that means there's a means to it. And then we begin looking for the means rather than not looking whatsoever. And I think that's one of the important things that comes out of that, is learning something new about that. It tells us that we're not alone in the universe, but it also suggests a way that we may be able to explore part of our galaxy ourselves. And I think that's one of the important things to come out of it. And we get hints about it. We learn that the Air Force at one time was going to set up spectroscopic cameras around the country to see if they could photograph the light coming from UFOs and get a spectroscopic analysis. I'm not sure exactly what that would have revealed to them, but it might have given them a hint about the propulsion system. So, you know, something like that. Or we got a glowing object, the metallic structure of the craft. I don't know what all it would have told us. If they had the cameras out and located, we might have gotten photographs of the object independently from two or three locations, and that would tell us a great deal about its capabilities. How high was it flying? How fast it was going? How large was it? All those sorts of things we could have divined from a proper investigation. You can see in the Project Blue Book files, as we look through those, these sorts of things were attempted, but only haphazardly. They were going to put out some cameras, but well, we got one camera, so that's not much. Ed Rupelt, who was the Chief of Project Blue Book at one time, talked about the green fireballs which were seen over the desert southwest in great numbers in the late 1940s, and they were going to set up cameras to photograph the green fireballs. Apparently, they did set up a camera, and apparently they got pictures because there's hints to it, but the pictures never show up. We don't know where the pictures went, we don't know who has those pictures, we don't know where they went. If we do have a crashed UFO, as Roswell seems to suggest, and we can figure out how it works, then we take a big step over our competitors in the world, but we also learn how to travel interstellar distances. And I think the technology may be so far beyond our capability to understand at this point, we haven't figured it out. And the best example, it worked much better in the 1990s, is if you take a VCR, a power pack, and a TV set back to Merlin the Magician, and you show him the videotape, which is basically a black ribbon. And if you know how to decode it, show him how you put it in the machine, and you can see pictures and sound, the color pictures and sound. To duplicate that, he's got to understand two things that are invisible, electricity and magnetism. And he just did not have the cultural elements to understand that in the time of Merlin the Magician. And I think we may be at that point, we're presented with this technology, we do not have the technological ability to understand what all we've been presented with. I think we continue to work on it, and as our technology evolves, we apply it. But I don't think we figured much of it out yet.
People who listen to the podcast will appreciate, I like a good analogy. So I like that Merlin one. I'll probably steal that going forward at times, Kevin, if you don't mind.
Just credit me with it.
Always give credit, always will. And if I don't, people can pull me up on that. You've mentioned there obviously some common factors. Is there anything you've noticed in your years of writing, investigation and research that have given you any clues as to the craft's origin? You've mentioned interstellar travel, people potentially visiting from different galaxies. What, for you, is your best summary you can put together of what this phenomenon may be?
I would say it's not interplanetary, meaning it doesn't come from inside the solar system, because we pretty well surveyed all the bodies in the solar system that could have intelligent life on it producing these sorts of things. And we realize that Jupiter and Saturn are impossible, the same with Uranus and Neptune. Pluto is way out there in the cold world. There's really nothing apparently on Mars. Venus, you land your spacecraft on Venus and it's going to melt. And Mercury is kind of out of the question. Some of the moons around the planets, a Titan, for example, around the site, Saturn, would be more Earth-like. But then you've got a problem with the temperatures and things like that. So I think we pretty well ruled out interplanetary flight. And I think in the 1950s, the late 1940s, 1950s, they were thinking in terms of interplanetary flight as opposed to interstellar. When we move beyond that, I would guess, and it's only a guess, that they would come from within our galactic neighborhood. A hundred light-years away, fifty light-years away. I don't know how fast they can travel. I don't know how they would maneuver. They may be able to cross the galaxy in a matter of hours, based on their technology or a way of warping space to shorten those distances. I don't know, and if I had an answer to that, I'd be really, really rich, and I wouldn't be doing podcasts. I'd be on my mega-yacht, having a good time somewhere, or flying around in my private aircraft, flipping off people. I don't know. But I mean, the point is, I really don't know. We used to say that the only real clue we had was from the Betty Hill star map from her and Barney Hill's abduction in 1961. And she produced this star map. And Marjorie Fish created a 3D model and pegged it as being zeta 1, zeta 2 reticuli, which is a double star system sum, 37.5 light years from Earth. But that information is flawed because according to Betty Hill, it was a 3D representation she saw and she was drawing it in two dimensions, so that would have distorted it. Marjorie Fish, when she did her work, eliminated all red dwarf stars because she deduced there would be nothing around a red dwarf that would be of interest to a spacefaring race. And my counter argument would be that there may not be any civilized planets around that, but there may be some element that is crucial for them that they could find in one or two of these systems. So it may be important for them to look at red dwarfs. I don't know. There has been some work done suggesting better distances to those planet or those star systems that Marjorie Fish identified, are not where she thought they were. So the star map is kind of distorted there, but that was the only clue we really had. If you remember the movie Alien, the star system they go into is Zeta 1, Zeta 2 Reticuli. They mentioned that. I caught that some years later as I was watching the movie. I said, oh my God, they're there. That's where they found the alien. But I don't think that's relevant. But I really don't know. I just can't say, I would say that they come from inside our galaxy. Our galaxy is what, 110,000 light years across and 30,000 light years deep or something like that. We're on the outer edges, the fringes of the galaxy. So you could be talking about somebody who's 100,000 light years away. Then you move to other galaxies. I think the nearest galaxy is Andromeda, and it's what, 2.5 million light years away. So I can't see them traversing that distance. But if there's a way of bending space, maybe it is all things are possible. I don't know. So I don't know where they're coming. That's a long-winded answer to say, I don't know.
No, that's fair enough. But do you know what gives me a little bit of hope is, like you say, when you think about it seems impossible, and it's incomprehensible that we could traverse that distance, that level of space. But like you say, when Merlin saw the videotape, and saw that black ribbon, and then saw pictures on a screen, that would have seemed impossible as well. So there just might be that something that one day is really common that we don't quite understand yet. What I would like to put to you, Kevin, just before we get to some listener questions, I heard you on on Herbert Hughes' Unexplained radio show a couple of weeks ago. And you said there's been a lot of progress people have talked about that has been made in recent years, and some folks are getting really excited. We're going to get some form of disclosure from the government, something like that. But you said, like others have, that you've seen this before, you've experienced this, that it's potentially going to just fizzle away. The government are going to keep things classified. They're not going to get the reports that are due. Is there anything you have seen that you think maybe this time something could or maybe a little bit different that we get some form of progress on this subject?
You have to look at it from the point of view of the deep state, and you have to look at from the point view of the purpose of the deep state is to keep the deep state in power and keep those in those positions of power well-financed. They have no motivation to release the information. There's absolutely nothing they gain by releasing the information, and in fact, it could undercut their power. I did a book called UFOs in the deep state that came out what a year ago, something like that, and looked at this in depth, and people say, well, why do they continue to keep it classified? If you look at the way, at least our government works here in the United States, you have a transition of power at the very top, the president every eight years at least. Sometimes it's only four years, sometimes it's eight years, depending on the president and the elections. But the people they bring into the government, you see the names coming up again and again and again. People who were in the Clinton administration in the 1990s are showing up in the Biden administration in some of the top level spots. And the bureaucrats stay there all the time. So bureaucrats who came to work in the Clinton administration are still working in their positions in the Biden administration. And they want to maintain their power and maintain their elite status. And I think that's one of the reasons we see the persistence of the secrecy. Anytime a technologically advanced civilization contacts a more primitive civilization, that primitive civilization ceases to exist. Not necessarily through contact or warfare, warfare or conquest, the mere contact. And there's a really great example from anthropological history where anthropologists want to study a primitive tribe. And the tribe have an underlying sociological structure, where if you needed a stone axe, you had to go through a ritual or a series of steps to get permission from the leaders of that society to use the stone axe. The anthropologist brought a number of steel axes with him and to induce people to talk with him about their society and thing like that. He'd give them a steel axe. He has now undercut one of the underpinnings of that society in an unintentionally, but he radically altered that society by the introduction of a steel axe, which is a far superior device than a stone axe. And I think they understand this, that the mere presence of this technology would radically alter our civilizations around the world. And if they introduce any of that technology to us, it's going to change the power structure. I think they fear that. I think the only way we're going to get disclosure is if the alien creatures decide it's time to let us know, and they land somewhere where the government can't cover it up, and the news media is there to interview them. Of course, we have to be careful we don't end up with To Serve Man, which was a wonderful Twilight episode. But the point simply is, I think that the way things are right now, there is no motivation by those in power to reveal the information they have about UFOs. We have hints about how extraordinary this information is, because we can see it in the way they bungled the investigation, but the information we've been able to gather since then that shows where their mistakes were made, and how they were manipulating the data to keep us all in the dark. It starts essentially in the United States with Roswell, and it continues on from that. We had the Robertson panel in 1953, which was CIA sponsored, and the conclusions were obviously written before the guys went to the work of studying the flying saucers and said, well, there's nothing to it, we need to just stop the mystique of flying saucers. We saw the same thing with the Condon Committee, which I think the skeptics still hold up as, here's a scientific investigation of UFOs, and yet the conclusions were written before the investigation began. An Air Force officer wrote to the Condon Committee and said, here's what we'd like you to find. And they wrote back and said, yeah, we can do that. I've got the letter, a copy of the letter up on my blog at www.kevinrandall.blogspot.com. Just type in Hippler letter and it'll take you to that information.
I'll put the blog address in the, I'm just making a note of that now for the listeners, because I tend to forget those in the description of the podcast as well, folks. And listen, on that, Kevin, time will tell. Hopefully, we do get that progress. But I've said on the podcast before, I completely understand folks who have been involved in this subject for a lot longer than myself and others who listen that why they are trepidatious and why they've seen this kind of thing happen before. So hopefully, we get something different, but I can see both points of view. Let's get to some listener questions, Kevin, in the time we have remaining. The first question is from Matt and Matt wants to know, did the egg-shaped objects at Levelland give off any noises?
There was discussion of people hearing sounds, yes. It wasn't universal, but they did hear roars, they did hear sounds, yes. There was noise given off, not only the electromagnetic effects, but also noise and of course, the very bright lights.
Was the noise reported as mechanical? Like you said, a roar, would it be something more mechanical or?
No, it was more of a roar, more of, I think you're more lined with a jet engine type thing. But it was that kind of thing, and not everybody reported sound.
And I think as well that you mentioned earlier about perception and at the time that people knew about flying saucers from the headlines in early science fiction, but it would have still been very much one's interpretation of what they were hearing or what they were seeing. Not like now because we've got 75 years of stories and books, and we've got Hollywood movies that we can interpret these things a little bit easier. So it still could have been something maybe a bit more, because a jet engine type noise or a roar isn't normally what we associate, is it with a UFO or a UAP? You tend to associate low hums or vibrations.
Well, I think that it really, again, I think it's the person and how they describe the sounds. And oftentimes the sound is sort of a secondary effect. They're just not really listening. They're looking at the thing in awe. You go through the reports of the people carefully and you can find hints of that sort of thing. It's kind of like the sheriff. If you go through an awful lot of the books published after 1957, which mentioned Levelland, and my own books do the same thing. Say the sheriff saw it, but it was just a streak of light in the distance. And now I got into it in depth. And it's not a streak of light in the distance. It's a solid object seen much closer. So I think we have to look at all of that sort of thing. Sometimes it's the interpretation of the witnesses. Sometimes it's the interpretation of the writers who are reporting on the story. Sometimes it's the government changing things around a little bit. And the writers do that too. They assume things based on what they're reading. Put their own interpretations on it. Sometimes if those interpretations are wrong, the next guy who's reading it puts that same interpretation on it because he read it in another book. And that's why I do something called Chasing Footnotes periodically. You read something about a book and there's a footnote. So you look at, well, what's that footnote saying? You go to that source, which may lead you to another source, which leads you to another source, which finally leads you to the original source. And the original source story is not quite the same as been reported in the latest book. So you have to look at all of those sorts of things as well.
It's a really interesting point. I think many of us, like you say, would take that at face value and say, yep, this is what's written. There's a footnote and like you say, a little bit of digging and you find out that's potentially changed. So interesting point. Mike has a question. During your research into the 1964 Lonnie Zamora incident that occurred near Sirocco, New Mexico, did you hear anything about Lonnie Zamora having a telepathic experience?
No.
Nothing on that?
No, I don't think there's anything to that. I did hear that he was supposedly a drunk, but that's not true either. I think that was another way of belittling the sighting. Lonnie Zamora was a very quiet religious man. And I think this experience frightened him. The Socorro experience frightened him. But in the book I did on Socorro, we look at in depth some of the explanations for it. We find out that something else is important. It's not a single witness case. There are other witnesses that witnessed aspects of the case, either just before Zamora's sighting or hours afterwards. Sometimes it's just a roar in the sky or a blue flame in the sky, and others it's something much better. But you have to look at the whole area in April of 1964, that short period of time around the sighting, and you get some very good information about what he had seen. And of course, there was a big roar associated with that craft.
Next question is from Ryan, and Ryan wants to know, could the genetic bottleneck that occurred roughly 70,000 years ago have been due to extraterrestrial intervention? Do you think hybridization could be a goal of such intervention?
I really don't know. I haven't studied, I did study anthropology, and I understand how some of these things work, but I just haven't looked at that in depth. That's one of the many, many side facets of the UFO field, like crop circles and cattle mutilations and abductions and all the crash retrievals. And I've spent most of my research looking at more of the contemporary sightings and the crash retrievals, and the sightings that have multiple witnesses and multiple chains of evidence as opposed to looking something that's very speculative about what they might have done, or how they might have manipulated the human race at some point.
Fair enough. Next up is Jason out in Los Angeles asks, in your opinion, what would be a legitimate or justifiable reason for any world government to keep the full truth of UFOs from its citizens? What would be a reason that would make you think, yeah, it's best we don't tell the general public about that?
I would have said years ago, it may be a religious aspect that would cause undue panic, or the mere knowledge that there's alien creatures out there that may be on the brink of invading the earth, that would have caused panic. I think that pretty well is untrue. I've talked to a number of theologians about this, and they think it would not affect the religions all that much. And I think that we're all now sophisticated enough to understand that if these things have been around for 75 or 80 years, that the invasion probably isn't coming any time soon. It's done nothing to affect my life, so I'm not really worried about it. I think the motivation, again, that was always a question. What's the motivation for the governments suppressing the information? And I think it just has to do with them maintaining their own power and their fear that if the information gets out, it's going to undermine their power in some way. And they're doing everything they can to maintain their power and their financial positions in the world.
On a similar topic, Gnosis, who is a big contributor to the podcast on the Discord channel as well, says, Kevin clearly believes in a deep state infrastructure that has kept the topic secret over many years. Why have we had no smoking gun whistleblowers or deathbed confessions? Do you think it's because those at the top are still confused by the nature of the phenomenon? Or like you said a little bit there, Kevin, could it just be there are dark aspects to the phenomenon that create a natural justification to keep it secret?
First of all, I would say that there really are no deathbed confessions because a deathbed confession by definition must be the admission of committing a crime at some point in your life. If you're on your deathbed and you start talking about flying saucers, it really isn't a deathbed confession by the legal definition. I always like to throw that out for no good reason whatsoever.
That's fair.
But I think that there have been some interesting things. Edwin Easley, who I mentioned earlier was the Provost Marshall of Walliswold, literally on his deathbed mentioned the creatures to his family. Yet when that information is transmitted into the public arena, you see the skeptics doing everything in their power to belittle it. Well, Randall himself didn't witness him saying that. No, I didn't, but his family did, and this is what they told us. I think the problem is we have not gotten somebody who's really on the inside and can present some kind of evidence for that. We've got a lot of people that have talked about that. Some of the people's credibility is not very great. Others credibility is interesting, but all we have are rumors about it. I think it's that sort of thing that we're dealing with something that is basically unbelievable. You believe in flying sausage, men from other planets coming to earth. That's unbelievable. I think that to take that step over, it requires more than somebody in a deathbed confession environment saying, yes, this is what I saw and what I did. We need something more to be presented. If he said, go to my safe, and there's this metal, if you wad it up in a ball and you let it go, it unfolds itself. Well, then you've got something more than just their word on what happened. So I think that's one of the problems we've run into is, you need something more than just these stories. We've got lots of those stories and some of them are from people who are very credible, and some of them are from people who just really aren't very credible at all.
And final listener question from Dave Smethurst. What are Kevin's views on USOs, so unidentified submerged objects, and the possibility of underwater bases? I believe there was a lot of activity off the coast of Vietnam during that conflict.
Well, I saw none of that during that conflict because I was busy doing other things. But there's another subset of the UFO phenomena I really haven't looked at. I will say the Shegg Harbor case, where this thing was seen to plunge into the ocean, and I think of it as more a forced landing as opposed to a crash, because apparently they repaired the craft and they got out of there some days later. I just really haven't looked at that in-depth, but it makes sense if you have the capability of traveling interstellar distances, you may have capability of hiding your base under the ocean, so it'd be very hard for us to detect or on the dark side of the moon or something like that. But I just really haven't looked into that in-depth at all.
It sounds like you've got plenty of books left in you, so I think there's some food for thought within that though, Kevin, even if you are planning on slowing down, like you say. Listen, Kevin, I just want to ask you one more thing about the book, Levelland, what do you want people to take away from reading this book?
What they ought to take away from is how the government manipulated the data that had we done a proper investigation in 1957, we'd be having a whole different conversation about it. I think the evidence is there for something very, very extracurricular of having have it there. I think it's ranked right below the Roswell case because of the number of witnesses and the possibility of good, solid evidence, the interactions with the environment. I think looking at that and seeing how the government manipulated the information and how they kept us from understanding it. I should point out, this was not a phenomenon related just to Levelland, Texas in 1957. The book also covers the French sightings from 1954, and the South American sightings from 1954. In fact, the very first case of electromagnetic effect is from 1909 and is from England. It covers a whole gambit of this kind of thing, the electromagnetic effects related to UFO sightings.
Kevin, you've mentioned you've got a new book coming out in March, which is going to be on Roswell, or it'll be in time for the 75th anniversary. I think it's due in by March, was that right?
I have a book coming out in March, but it's about Project Moondust. And of course, Levelland is out now, and the Roswell book will be out closer to the anniversary of the sighting in Roswell, which is July of 1947. I think it is the third book in my city's trilogy, going with Roswell to Socorro now to, and with Levelland. So it's all part of my series of the city's trilogy.
Well, I'll have the links in the description of how people can pick up Levelland. I'll have a flying disc press, the links in there as well from. I've got speaker, author, researcher, and creator of the Archive of the Impossible at Rice University, Dr. Geoffrey Cripple. Geoff, welcome to the podcast.
Thanks, Andy. Happy to be here even though it took a long time.
It did. And you have been someone that people have, I don't just say this because it would be BS otherwise, but people have asked to have you on for quite a while. So it's nice to finally get this one over the line as such. If it goes really badly, no one ever has to hear it. I just won't release it, but that's never been the case yet. I'm looking forward to it. And Geoff, there's a whole lot of ground to cover or potentially with you that I feel we're going to have to get you back on at another time to cover various aspects that might be a little bit of a sidebar. But I also want to cover your recent time at the Saul Foundations Inaugural Conference. But I want to start off talking about you, your own background and what's been your journey to getting to this point, discussing quote unquote, the impossible.
Yeah, I mean, it's been a long journey. I'm 61 years old and my journey began probably as a child. I was uber pious. I was super pious. I grew up Roman Catholic in a German farm family and small business owner in Nebraska, in the middle of the US. And I became very religious and I wanted to be a monk. And I joined a seminary and trained essentially to become a monk and I fell in love with the comparative study of religion when I was in this Benedictine seminary. And so I went on to graduate school in a secular university, University of Chicago, and became someone who studies religion comparatively. I started out in India. I then switched to California and the American counterculture. And so there's a long journey there. There's a long, I mean, I've done a lot of different things, including medieval Christianity, modern Hinduism, and the modern counterculture. I got interested in what I call the impossible today through looking at the counterculture. I sat down with a lot of people, I talked to a lot of people who told me really incredible stories that I knew didn't happen, but that I knew happened. And I had heard these stories before in the past in historical texts, and we were always trained to think of these as exaggerations, or as power plays, or perhaps even as just lies. And I realized that none of that quite worked. Actually, it didn't work at all. It wasn't just, it didn't quite work. It was clearly not true. And so, I got really interested in the early 2000s in this disconnect between people's extraordinary experiences and how academics or intellectuals simply won't treat them, simply don't think about them. And so, I turned to those pretty intensely, and I wrote a couple books. One was called Mutants and Mystics, which was really on superhero comics and science fiction, and The Paranormal Experiences of Artists and Authors, really, behind those stories. And I wrote a book right before that called Authors of the Impossible, which is really my theory of what the paranormal is about. And the book basically argues that it's very much about language and communication and information and that it's really what creates the stories or the narratives that then later become religion or culture or civilization. And I don't mean that in a reductive way, Andy. I wasn't arguing that the paranormal is simply about language. I was arguing that language itself, there's something paranormal about language, and that when we write about the paranormal, it also writes us in a really weird and eerie way. And so I was trying to get at this sort of deeper question about the paranormal and how it produces a story and how we're all embedded in these stories, whether we know it or not. And that's really what got me into this. The UFO thing, I had to write about the UFO when I wrote about the American counterculture because UFOs are everywhere in the 60s and 70s in the US. And you just can't avoid the topic. But as I got into the paranormal more broadly, it hit me hard that a lot of the experiences people talk about in the UFO experience are not unique to the UFO phenomenon. You find them in your death experiences, you find them in precognitive dreaming, you find them in entity encounters, you find them in legends and folklore and myth and all over the place. And so I approach the UFO phenomenon very much as someone who looks at these things cross-controversially. That's kind of where I am today.
It's a really interesting way to get to this, like you say, from that beginning, looking to go into being a monk and how you can segue into this. Not totally unrelated, obviously, with the religious aspect on things. Had you ever had any sort of either paranormal or UFO experience growing up or through into adulthood?
Yeah, everybody asked me that. Yes and no. My professional work and my writing about these things is not dependent on my own experiences. But it relies on them for a kind of sympathy or solidarity. I have to say that. I had one sort of overwhelming paranormal experience in Calcutta in the fall of 1989 that I often talk about. It involved an out-of-body experience while I was sleeping and a state of a sort of subtle energy invasion or abduction, I suppose we'd say now. I didn't have that language then. This was 1989. I wouldn't have spoken of this as an abduction experience, but it had all the marks of one. But it made a lot of sense in the context of the Shakti Tantra and the kind of the religious and cultural tradition I was studying at the time. And that struck me, you know, there was something about the Bengali religious context that made this experience not only possible but plausible. And so that sort of, I suppose, that's kind of one source of my conviction that this has something to do with religion, has something to do with human spirituality. In terms of the UFO, I actually didn't think I had ever had such an experience. And I was sitting, I was watching, it was actually America, America's Got Talent was the show. And I was sitting there with my mother who was visiting from another town and this really bad car commercial came on with this stupid flying saucer on a string. You know, it was clearly a hoax. And my mom turns to me and she says, well, Jeff, do you remember the time we saw one of those? And I was like, no, I have no memory. And she proceeded to tell me this extraordinary story of not only seeing a UFO, but it was a large rectangular craft in the sky over northern Nebraska. And it occurred at night. And she said it was so dramatic that we pulled over. We pulled the car over and all four of us got out and looked at this thing in the sky. And my first reaction was, oh, it had something to do with the Air Force Base in Omaha, which is, you know, not a couple hundred miles from there. She said, no, this was rectangular and it obviously couldn't fly, but there it was in the sky. And so, I mean, obviously, I had an encounter, but I don't remember it.
It wasn't life-defining as such at that moment. And I think it's fair. You mentioned that bias that you don't have just because you've had some sort of experience, and that's completely fair. I use my own couple of sightings as such that I would never call experiences, because I think I've spoken to enough individuals who have had true experiences to know that minds were just sightings, but you wouldn't believe them. I don't think I would believe if someone told me some time ago, they saw what I saw.
Yeah.
So I think it's unfair for me to judge completely, even though I may be hypocritical in that time, so I'll say, I don't think so. But I think you'd allow that opinion, aren't you?
You know, something, one close mentor of mine is Jacques Vallee, and something he says a lot is, he wouldn't believe any of the data had he not seen a flying saucer in broad daylight over a suburb in Paris in 1955. I mean, it was just like, there it is. It's as clear as the car going down the highway or my neighbor friend. This isn't something I can question. So it's that minor experience that I think creates a kind of sympathy or solidarity. And so when people were telling me these stories in California in the 2000s, I was like, oh yeah, that can happen. You know, I mean, because it happened to me. I was literally out of my body and I had a kind of energetic download and I had the whole shebang. And so I was like, yeah, I think you're telling me the truth.
Yeah. It's a strange one. And that's, I wonder, is that sort of small experience enough that has that knock on effect, especially someone as dramatic as Jacques Vallee and the impact he has in the UFO topic and UFO community over the decades. Like you say, had he not had that experience, does he ever get involved at all, especially in the way he has?
I don't know. That's a good question. I think there were a couple of things in Jacques' early life that shaped him. One was seeing the flying saucer over the suburb in Paris in Pontoire, but the other was working at the observatory and hearing his fellow scientists mock and make fun of Amy Michel. And Jacques was a correspondent with Amy Michel, and he found their attitudes really arrogant and bizarre. And so I think it was this combination of having such an experience and seeing how the topic was treated by cultural elites that really turned Jacques into who he became. And that in his, you know, his absorption in esoteric literature, I think is deeply informative. I think that's not often talked about here, but he certainly talks about it. He certainly writes about it. So I think that's a big part of this, this, this quote. And that's, that's how I connected to Lele's books. When I first read them as a historian of religions, I was like, oh, here is a man doing the history of religions. I mean, here is someone who clearly understands the history of folklore and mythology and religion and who also clearly understands the physics and the astronomy and the computer science. So to me, it was that combination that was so stunning and kind of blew me away. It wasn't one of the other. I had had a lot of the history of religions. I knew that intimately. I had studied science. I did not have that intimately, but it wasn't one or the other. There was the two together.
I often think it just takes that small action for things to change for people. I like analogies now and again. This might be a good one, might be a terrible one. I'll let you be the judge of that. But if you're sitting on a bus and it's a cold winter's morning, the windows are frosted up. You can't see out the windows and everyone's on the bus. You're all having the same experience. You're all going to somewhere. You may get off sooner or later. However, I'm the guy who likes to roll his sleeve up and polish the window so I can see outside. Now, I'm now having a totally different experience because of what I can see through this little window I've created for myself, whether it's curiosity or nosiness or just habit, I don't know. But everyone else on the bus potentially could be seeing the same thing, but they don't because they choose to look ahead, stare out the window at the front and see the same thing as everyone else. And that just makes me wonder, is it just those small differences or small curiosities that either get folks involved in the impossible, the paranormal, this phenomenon, that maybe stop others not ever getting involved or seeing what others could see?
I think with the paranormal, it's a bit trickier because so many paranormal experiences are negative. They're terrifying. So it's not just that you don't rub your window, it's that you want the shade down.
You don't want to.
So you're not going to let the critter inside the bus. It's sort of like putting the covers over your head as a child or being afraid of going to sleep with the window open, which is what I had when I was a little boy. So I think it's more than that. It's more than a lack of curiosity. There's a genuine fear that people experience. I also think, you know, one of my jokes about paranormal events is that they're trying to get our attention. And what academics and also frankly, what religious people often do is they essentially say, ignore the event. You know, either ignore it because it's crazy and stupid and it's gonna tempt you away from your scientific or rational worldview, which is what I think academics or conventional scientists often think. Or if you're a religious believer, it's going to distract you from the contemplative goal or from the salvific goal of the religion in question. But it's happening and it's trying desperately to call us into some kind of reflection on the story we're caught in. And so I personally think that these things need to be paid attention to. It doesn't mean we need to believe them or bow down to them. I'm not suggesting that, but we need to listen to them and to take them very seriously as nudges or, you know, pushes sometimes.
In that case, a lot of folks tend to these days put the paranormal. And I think if I say the paranormal, you're talking entities, spirits, ghosts. That's what I think of personally. Under the same umbrella as the UFO phenomenon, do you still think there's quite a distinct difference between those experiences?
No, I don't think there's a distinct difference. I mean, I'm with Jacques on this one. And that gets us into trouble, of course, because some people in the UFO world want to suggest it's nuts and bolts. It's a technology. It's a physical craft. And I'm not denying that, but it's also an apparition and a vision. And people who have these encounters often develop extraordinary abilities. They become precognitive, or they become clairvoyant, or they begin to have dreams. So whatever these objects are, they have psychic or spiritual effects on relatively hairless monkeys, i.e. us. And for me, the definition of the paranormal is something that is occurring in the physical environment and the mental world at the same time. It's not one or the other. It's not a hallucination. It's not just a subjective illusion. On the other hand, it's not simply a chair or a wall or a craft out there either. It somehow is participating in both realities. And that just shatters all of our boxes. We don't have a way of thinking about that because we as bodies and brains are splitting up the world constantly into a mental dimension and a material dimension. And my strong suspicion is that's just not what the world is. It's how we split it up, but let's own that. Those are our divisions. Those are not divisions out there in reality.
Yeah. You mentioned the phrase previously in your books, thinking impossibly.
Yeah.
I think when I initially see, when I first started looking at your stuff a couple of years back, you know, archive of the impossible, my immediate thought, and it's not this is through Ripley's Believe It or Not, that type of thing that, you know, it's just kind of weird and wacky things, but it's not, it's just that whole, to many, this is the impossible. There are no UFOs, there are no aliens, there are no ghosts, there are no paranormal, but that's what the impossible is, isn't it? And if you could explain that for us, what is thinking impossibly?
Sure. So what I mean by the impossible is something essentially philosophical. And essentially what I mean is that what is possible or impossible is the function of a particular worldview. It's not a function of reality. You know, things that are impossible in one worldview still happen, but they're just ignored or they're dismissed. And things change from worldview to worldview in a really radical way. I know that as a historian of religions. I mean, things happen in some religious contexts that don't happen in other religious contexts. And so there's something about reality, there's something about possibility and impossibility that's really a function of the human being. It's not a function of reality. Reality itself is impossible all the time, but it's still possible, it still happens. And let me give you an example, because I'm just babbling.
No, no, go on.
Take rocks that fall from the sky. You know, in the 16th century, French peasants were reporting these rocks falling out of the sky and into their field, and often they were on fire. And the scientists in the cities were just like, these farmers are idiots. You know, rocks don't fall from the sky, for God's sake. That's stupid. But of course, the peasants were right. They were absolutely correct about the things that they were witnessing. And what we needed was a new model of outer space to make sense of why in fact, actually rocks do fall from the sky. And, you know, we call the meteorites now. And so what happened there is not that the phenomena changed, but that our model of the universe changed to encompass and keep on the table those things that were always happening, but that the scientific elites were saying were impossible. And that's what I'm saying about all these other things, Andy. I'm saying, look, what we need as a model or a framework to keep all this stuff on the table and not to keep shoving it off the table and telling us silly things like that it doesn't happen or it can't happen. Of course, it happens. Of course, it can happen. It does all the time. Stop saying that. Change your view of what reality is or what the natural world is or how it works so that we can start thinking about these things in a more coherent and humane way.
Those changes throughout history don't normally happen in an instant, usually as a chain reaction or a slow process over time. Is that a phase you think we may be in right now?
I wish. I think we're in a lot of confusion. And I think we're in a lot of trouble actually. And I think a lot of that's because of our religions and not just because of our science. You know, a lot of the resistance to paranormal phenomena is religious resistance. The religious people essentially say this is real, but it's demonic. And that does not help. That does not get us very far. And it also ignores the fact that what every student of religion knows, really from class one, is that the sacred has a negative aspect and a positive aspect. The demon is as numinous as the angel, and the devil is as divine as God is, you know, in the history of religions now. I know that's a heretical thing to say, but in the larger history of religions, it's certainly true that the sacred is not this force or this energy that's always beneficent and helpful. In fact, it's often terrifying, and it will sometimes kill people. It's more like radioactive energy than it is, you know, the angel or the unicorn in your daughter's bedroom. And so I think once we step into a larger historical framework and we recognize that the numinous is more like an energy or a power that is appearing in the environment, then we are much less likely to say, oh, it's negative, therefore, we have to resist it. No, you don't have to resist it. You have to understand it and you have to treat it differently, perhaps, but you don't have to deny it. So that's really what I'm getting at. I worry a lot as a historian of religions about, frankly, religion and the kind of, frankly, the stupidity of our religions, the ignorance of our religions and how they do not deal adequately with these things. They offer us something important. There's a kind of transcendent or vertical dimension to our religions. It's very useful and very powerful, but their widespread condemnation of these phenomena is really destructive, I think, at the end of the day.
I'm not religious in the slightest myself, but I appreciate other people can be to varying degrees. And I've always said in terms of various religions with a limited knowledge of them, they can't all be right, but they can certainly all be wrong. And I just wonder, given the differences between various religions, I know they have similarities at times, depending on the religion to religion, but given the differences, does that just show that we're potentially as a species, not in a place that we can accept, you know, a non-human intelligence being declared or visiting as you know?
Well, okay, so let's go to that. Let's go to the US and let's go to the language of non-human intelligence. And let's go to Congress and, you know, the whistleblowers and everything that's going on today. You know, politicians are people, too, and their voters are religious in all kinds of ways. And military people, it turns out, are people, too. So are scientists. They're all people. And if you talk to people who have run some of these programs, some of these classified programs, they will often tell you that where they really met resistance was in the military or in the government from very religious military leaders or politicians. And they met resistance on religious grounds, not on military grounds or not on intellectual grounds, but on religious grounds. And that's, I suppose, that's what I'm most worried about. And I'll give you a good example. In the US now, the UFO phenomena is generally understood within what I call the alien invasion narrative. There's a mythology that the alien is somehow invading our sacred airspace. And therefore, what we should be about is fighting, fighting this alien force and pushing back on this, quote unquote, threat. Okay? That's extremely dangerous. Because for one thing, I think these non-human intelligences, if we want to call them that, have been with us for thousands of years. If they wanted to kill us, trust me, we would have been food a long time ago. There's no question in my mind about that. So this attitude we have of fighting back or treating these as threats is really a projection of our own violence and our own really ignorance about what's going on, I think. And I think what you see in the States, or see what you see in North America, let's say more broadly, is a gradual move out of that alien invasion narrative into something that I think is much more powerful and much more positive. So if we want to stick to movies, if Independence Day appeared in the 1990s, all about punching out the alien as it were, arrival happened in 2017 or 2016. And if you watch the movie Arrival, the military doesn't do anything at all. It's actually, the military stands back, and it turns out the reason the alien presence is there is to communicate with human beings because we need each other. And they're going to teach us about the circular nature of time, and we're going to do something for them in 3,000 years, which they somehow know about. So, it's a complete break, is what I'm trying to say. And I know it's a movie, Andy. I'm not saying, Arrivals to Truth and Independence Day is not... I'm not saying that. I'm saying, no, these are cultural narratives that appear, and they grab the public in particular ways. And the way the public has been grabbed, at least in the US over the last 60, 70 years, is through the Cold War, frankly. And all we can imagine is this alien. I mean, we use the same word, alien, for an illegal immigrant, as we do a non-human intelligence. And in France, they used the word for someone who was mentally ill. I mean, what does that tell you? So I think there are resources in history to think about this, and we have to be more aware of the cultural narrative or the mythology, as we call it in my field, that is driving the whole thing. And a mythology is not a bad story or a false story. It's a story so deep that we don't know it's a story. It's the water the fish are swimming in. And I think we're in such a story right now. And I think what these paranormal events are trying to do is say, hey, wake up. You're in a story. You're in a story. You're in a movie. Don't you see that? Don't you want to change the story? Do you really like this movie you're in? Because guess what? It ain't working so well for a lot of people. But we're caught in these narratives. And I think what these events are trying to do is essentially shock us out of that.
I think as well, it's a fair point you raise around these experiences. And perception is a big thing. And I wonder, like, if I go into my son's bedroom at night when he's sleeping before I go to bed and tuck him in and accidentally, you know, nudge him and he wakes up out of his dream with a fright. I'm not doing anything malicious there. But how he perceives that is someone's in my room, I've just woken up. I'm scared. My heart starts racing. He sweats and he might cry. But from my point of view, I didn't mean that. I was trying to do something else and it came from a good place. His perception of what's happened could be completely different. And actually, true story, Jeff, just a few days ago, I woke up in the middle of the night. And one of my recurring dreams since childhood, which always terrifies me, is waking up, the door opens and no one's there. And I woke up during the night, looked over at the door, just getting a sense of something was not quite right, thinking I've just woken up, whatever it might be, and the door opens. And my son steps in. But just from the hall light being on in a silhouette, I was terrified. He just wanted to come in, because he'd woken up during the night and needed the toilet, that was it. But perception in these events can be a big thing. And I wonder, is that a sort of what goes on with some of these incidents?
I think that does sometimes go on. I also think it's more than that. Let me give you another example. Take our dog, which you may have heard earlier, her name is Delilah. Well, I take her to the veterinarian, and the poor thing just shakes. She shakes uncontrollably because that veterinarian is going to do things like put her out and take teeth out of her mouth and poke her and do all kinds of things that poor Delilah has no idea what's going on. And so, okay, I intend good by that. I intend to take care of Delilah, but she doesn't know that. Yeah. Yeah. On the other hand, I eat meat. You know, what is a cow's relationship to a human being? We, I grew up taking care of cattle, as it were, but it was so that they could be slaughtered, and we could eat hamburgers and steaks. So are human beings not demonic vis a vis cows? It sure looks like it. If I was a cow, I would be very distrustful of human beings. And so these non-human intelligences we talk about as demons, well, maybe they are demonic in some sense. Maybe their intentions are not ours. Fine. But our intentions are not those of the other species we interact with either. So I guess I'm just trying to get us to expand our sense of what a value and morality. And I also can tell you, again, as a historian of religions, that the word demon, it just comes from the Greek daimon. And the daimon is not this evil being. The thing with horns and tail and all that stuff you get out of Christian myth, it all comes from a Christian daimonization of the god Panpon, you know? It's essentially a cultural war that the Christians won and the Greeks and the Romans lost. And okay, well, once you know that, it's like, well, come on. I mean, why are you still talking about daimons as if somehow these are obviously true? No, that's just a cultural war that people won, you know, thousands of years ago. And you're just beating up on other people right now.
Interesting. It just makes me think how the common depiction of Santa Claus is Coca-Cola. So, you know, that's, and that's it. That's what people know, but, you know, great market employee. Some of that expanding of thinking like you're talking about, people are trying to do this through various different ways. Folks like yourself have got conferences going on. And before we talk about the Seoul Conference, let's mention your own events that were hosted in 2022 and 2023 under your Archive of the Impossible banner. Can you talk about those and what those aim to achieve?
Yeah, I can. I'd love to talk about those. You know, when I was at the Seoul Foundation at Stanford, it reminded me a lot of our own conferences at Rice, by the way. But but in a very different sense, we. I decided to hold these two conferences in 2022 and 2023 to sort of announce our archival project to the world. We we have about 15 collections now in this archive, well over a million documents. They were actually started by Jacques Vallee, who approached me in about 2014, asking for help to place his files and correspondence in a university archive. I went back to my own institution and say, hey, can we do this? And it turns out we could. And so we initiated this with Jacques, but then a whole bunch of other researchers then essentially gave us their life work. And I felt that this was a really important thing to do in the humanities and the social sciences and the sciences. And so to hold these conferences, when we did that, it shattered every IT model that the university had. The response was incredible, Andy. Just to give you an example, when we host a lecture, we typically get about 500 views for the entire life of the lecture. We had 150,000 views in two weeks. You know, it was just like, it was like global and it was overwhelming. And our IT people were just like, oh my God, what is going on? And these were huge events. This is about 200 people came at each of these events. And I hosted about 30 different academics and experiencers, really from around the world, from Argentina to France to Canada, to the US., to the UK. And my experience of it was that intellectuals very much want to do this. They very much want to talk about these things, but they generally lack a context or a community of other intellectuals, historians, philosophers, anthropologists, you name it, doing it. And so what these conferences do is they provide that context. They provide that community and people come in from all over the world, either physically or online, and they can watch these addresses and take part in this conversation.
Have you got plans to host another in 2024?
So I'm on leave at the moment, sabbatical. I spent four years at a dean's office. I'm exhausted, to be honest. I've been dealing with other people's problems for four years, and I'm just fricking tired. So there won't be one in 2024. I do hope to have one in 2025, and then to keep going. I should add that they're very expensive, Andy. So I have to raise money every time I do one of these. And when I say very expensive, I mean, there are three or four times what it costs to hold a regular conference, because there's just so many people coming. There's so much food involved. There's so much travel. There's so much room and board. So I have to be careful about the money, to be really practical about it.
No, that's completely fair. And I think that's something that Dr. Gary Nolan and Dr. Peter Scaffish, who we'll go on to talk about now as well, will attest to in their own hosting of the Saul Foundation. Now, as we record this, it's early December, Saturday the 2nd of December, to give folks a peek behind the curtain. Dr. Nolan, as of yet, hasn't given the full official green light for the information on the Saul Foundation to be discussed at length. That was something he asked for as a sort of academic handshake beforehand that people who attend don't share things online, keep it private. And as much as possible, once he gives the green light a few weeks after, there will be videos, there'll be discussions and all sorts as well. That's sort of been adhered to, but this won't go out until the green light has been given, which I would expect will be any day now anyway. So we're going to talk about the Saul Foundation, but what was your experience? Obviously you were invited, you were a speaker on the Sunday, I believe. Was that correct?
I spoke on Saturday.
Oh, did you? Okay.
Yeah, I was the last speaker to speak formally. And I think Gary and Peter wanted me to talk last, to try to bring things into the present, but also to give a, I don't want to say a spiritual or religious, but a kind of existential meaning to the event. And I said pretty much what I said earlier. I come at this as a historian of religions. Much of the proceedings, as you no doubt know at Stanford, involve the sciences and public policy and politics. And that is very, it's a very different focus than we had at Rice. At Rice, the emphasis was very much on the humanities and the social sciences and on the experiencers themselves, really. So, I felt sitting there, you know, for the whole thing, and I saw the whole thing. I listened to every talk very carefully. I felt that the Rice event on the Archives of the Impossible and the Soul Foundation event were very complimentary. They were essentially two sides of the same coin, or two sides of the same floating sphere, if you want to be flatland about it. And I was frankly thrilled. I felt that the Stanford event was historic in the ways we normally use that word. I felt like the papers and presentations were excellent, but there was something about just holding the event in the medical school at Stanford University that was incredibly significant. And we finally had a voice, as it were. And so I think it was that authorization that was really what will be remembered about that event long after we've forgotten what individuals said.
Yeah, I think it's... And this is no disrespect to any other events or conferences that happened, but it's one thing renting an expo hall somewhere, a big empty shell, and filling it with stages and booths. But to have a credible facility like that, host an event that was clearly discussing, and let's put it bluntly, UFOs. And the science and the academia around that, it was a big thing. As much as Harvard with Avi Loeb, The New York Times, Leslie Kean, Ralph Blumenthal, Helene Cooper, you're starting to get some big organizational names entertaining the subject. And I think that's something that when I asked you earlier about, are we moving into that new phase? That's my hope that these big names continue to come on board. What were the conversations like for folks like yourself mingling? Because you were literally sitting next to these individuals, names that folks in UFOs will know well, folks that names who are now just becoming more prominent, such as a Carle Nell, what was that like?
Well, I knew a lot of these people, of course, before the event. And so part of it was simply meeting old friends. But again, there was this historical element to it. It was meeting a friend at an event that we knew on some level meant something. And I really want to emphasize that institutional or cultural cache that the organization had. Something similar, by the way, happened at Rice in the years before that, is that when the academics came, they recognized very quickly and clearly that we were treating the subject with a great deal of gravity and that this was a research university, and that all of the powers and all of the money and all of the stuff that a research university represents was being focused on this. And so that felt different as well, by the way. And I think when people have that voice and have that kind of space, they'll often say things that they certainly think, but they might not otherwise say. And I think that's what happened at Stanford, and I know that's what happened at Rice.
Your essay or talk was titled, well, given from what you sent me, shooting down souls, good luck with that, some paradoxical thoughts on the UFO phenomenon from a historian of religions. And I like that because something that came from the essay and what it sounds like is people can talk about this with a smile on their face and acknowledge, do you know what, some of this might sound ridiculous, but to appeal to those who are maybe not in the room yet, but looking through the door, looking through the window with an interest to try and get them in, you know, we're aware of what we're seeing, we're aware of the language being used, we're aware of the connotations, but here is out, let's have a conversation. And those, that multi-disciplined approach, I think is huge in getting this forward. So a lot of what you said within the essay, you've mentioned at the start of the podcast, but what were some of your, what did you want folks to take away from that overall talk?
Well, that the saucer and the soul are very much related. And that when people talk about these things as threats and want to shoot them down, they basically are talking about shooting down souls. And of course, that makes no sense, Andy. That's a category collision there. And that was the point of the joke. And that was kind of the point of the talk is, look, we're talking about things that are clearly related, but you're splitting them up in a way that is probably not truthful to what's going on. You know, I have to say, though, the other participants, that talk was received very well, by the way. And I don't believe for a second that there's any bad will or anything other than good intentions in everyone else. Everyone's trying to do the right thing. And the military and the political people who were there, they're just, they're trying to get this talked about, they're trying to get it on the table. And the truth is, is that the stuff in Congress and the whistleblowers has really helped the conversation. I mean, it really has given us a kind of, I don't want to say cover, but it's given us an authority in the culture that we certainly lacked. Before, you know, it was a kind of eye rolls, and there's always a joke of a tin foil hat or a little green man or something. Not so much anymore. People are like, wait a minute, something showing really is on the radar, and now the government's talk, we just have this bill with all these, this language of non-human intelligence. I mean, what's going on? You know, I mean, the giggle factor is not so funny anymore. And I think that that's really healthy. It's not a conclusion. It's not what we want, but it's better than we had. I'll put it that way.
And another theme within it is that resistance to normalization. You mentioned earlier as well that there's the giggle factor, I think, is a big barrier within that. And just I've always thought in the UK, we are even further behind the US in this conversation still. In the UK, if this story or if it appears in the news, it's a, and finally, and there is the X-Files music, we have the Flying Saucer goes by, the little green man waving at the screen, and there's a laugh and a joke. The same story could be positioned at the beginning of the news, at the top of the hour, really serious music with one of the top journalists presenting, and it has a whole different perception. How do you think we can get to the point where those stories do shift? How do we move it? And even, I don't know if you can talk for the UK, but we seem to really struggle with that here.
Yeah. So I think some of that is inevitable. I mean, you know, one of the phrases is thrown around a lot in the US is ontological shock. And that comes from, well, John Mack made it famous in the 90s, but it actually goes back to a theologian named Paul Tillich, believe it or not, in the 1950s. But what it refers to clearly in Mack is this notion that whatever is going on does actually does not feel, cannot be fit into our normal categories. And I do think that to the extent we normalize this or we make it reasonable or frankly scientific, we don't understand it. And that's a really hard message, Andy. People want their world to make sense and they want to know that the world can be fit into their boxes. And what I think a lot of these events tell us is that that's not true. So you know, I think the ontological shock is a problem. I also think, you know, this is Jeff now at 61. I talked to journalists, I talked to media people, I talked to television and film people. And in the back of my head, I'm just thinking, oh, you were, you were my student. And they of course were not my student. But what I'm thinking of is, oh, you're just, you're just another guy or another gal, or you're just another human being. You don't know what the hell you're talking about. And you're talking to me to try to figure it out. And I guess what? I don't know either. So let's just admit we don't know. But that's what people are really bad at admitting, including the media, frankly. The media can be really, really powerful and good, and it can really be stupid and bad. And I've seen both. And I think that's part of the problem. The other issue is people like me now, people in the academy have done a very poor job of communicating to the public about what we do. And I think that has to change. I think we have to grab the public space, and we're going to make mistakes. We're going to probably say things that you probably shouldn't say, things that are wrong. And that's okay. We're still going to get a message out there that I think is more sophisticated and nuanced than we have today.
I think that acceptance that people are still people at the end of the day, like you say, the military, politicians, scientists, academics are still individuals and there's going to be mistakes. And especially in the UFO community, but as well as many others online and social media, the slightest slip up or miscommunication or retelling of the same anecdote, but very slightly different gets jumped on and attacked. And that happens more and more. And I just wonder, the last week especially, Jeff, with politicians taking the stage and discussing UFOs in a big way right now in the US or UAP, I think it's shown that for many who wondered, and I don't know where I stand on this really historically, let's get politics involved in the UFO topic. Let's get them discussing UFOs in legislation. We've seen how much they've muddied the waters just in the space of a couple of weeks, and how heroes have become villains, and villains are starting to become heroes, and something in between is just getting a bit messy now.
Yeah. Again, I think the problem always is deeper than we can imagine. Take the political and the military stuff again. I mean, what people want to say is, the disinformation campaigns and the deception, this is all about the military or the politics or the bad actors. But the phenomena itself is deceptive. You know, and that's a function of intelligence, by the way. If you are intelligent, guess what? You're going to camouflage yourself. You're not going to tell your... The person studying the guerrilla tribe is not going to walk into the group of guerrillas and just do his or her thing. They're going to use some camouflage or deception. And I think that's... You know, one of the things I feel very strongly when I... After 20 years of this is that the phenomena itself is deceptive. It ain't what it seems to be, folks. But that's not... And that's not a bad thing necessarily. It just is. And I think once we understand that, we can... Again, we can be... This is what I meant by nuance and sophistication. And I think a lot of the conversation going on in the US. Congress and the US media is frankly naïve. And I just want them... Let me put it bluntly. When NASA puts together a team of intellectuals to study the UFO, I want them to put an anthropologist and a philosopher and a historian on there, too. For God's sake, don't give us just physicists and astronomers. Stop it. Stop. Just stop it. And I don't mean that the astronomers or the physicists don't have something to say. Of course they do. But so do the philosophers and the anthropologists and the historians. You need...
We need to listen to them as well. And that's what I suppose I say the most often. I call it my crabby stage. I mean, I'm in a crabby stage of life, but I really believe that, Andy. I really don't think science is gonna get us there at the end of the day. I think science combined with a historical and kind of humanistic approach will get us a little further, but one or the other, nope, ain't gonna work.
Let's start looking at some listener questions to kind of wrap up and summarize some of the topics we've looked at. So, Jeff, we had David emailed in to say, a spiritual person firmly believes that the spiritual world is divided into increasing levels of attainment, whereby over thousands of years, one's level may rise as our experience, knowledge and kindness and good works grow. Surely it's safe to assume that these non-human intelligences are many thousands of years in advance of us. Because of this huge disparity in advancement, is it safe to assume these entities cannot have any malevolent intent towards us?
I don't think we should assume anything. I mean, again, that notice that the email, I mean, it's like references are reference. There's a third or fourth person there. This model of some species being more advanced than other species, of course, is a post-Darwinian model that we assume. That's again, our myth. That's the mythology we live in and swim in. It may be true. Maybe these non-human intelligences are more highly evolved than us. I don't know, but I just want us to own that story. I want us to reflect on it and be aware that that's a post-Darwin kind of narrative.
A question from Newman. And again, this one's a little bit of a paragraph before we get to the question. So, with many of the explanations brought forward for paranormality sitting right at the edge of our knowledge and understanding of the world, what will it take in Jeffrey's opinion for scientists engaged in quantitative research to accept any evidence of events that exhibit quote-unquote high strangeness and not outright dismiss it as either law of large numbers, selection bias, magical thinking, or just glimpses of another one of Russell's teapots, claims being ultimately due to their obscure nature, unprovable by any study design or instrumentation?
Okay, that's a big question. I think this is where we need the historian of science to step in or the philosopher of science. And I think we need to be more humble about our science. My response to that question is not to say that these are somehow superior forms of knowledge, but these are not scientific forms of knowledge. Science is really good at studying objects and measuring them and predicting their behavior. Whatever is going on in these phenomena also has to do with subjectivity and mind and consciousness. And science is frankly really bad at that. The scientific method does not have a place in it for subjectivity or consciousness. So I just want to say, let's let science be science. Let's let it do what it does really, really well, but let's also acknowledge that some kinds of questions are not scientific questions. So that would be my answer to the email is, again, this is why you need historians and anthropologists and philosophers on the team as well, because they're going to call into question those scientific assumptions about reality. Let me put it this way. Just because science works doesn't mean materialism is true. That doesn't follow at all. But that's the assumption people, I think, often make, that what exists is what science can prove or establish. Well, that's not true. You know, again, scientists are people. They have feelings and emotions, and they love their children, and they have all kinds of things in their lives that cannot be measured, and that have nothing to do with their science. So, I just want to, again, call out our assumptions there.
I like that use of, you know, you can't measure love, but, you know, you still know it's there. So, someone can throw that back at Neil deGrasse Tyson one day, I think.
So, it's not just that, you know. My joke, Andy, is that, for example, a lot of paranormal phenomena involve trauma. And I mean serious trauma. I don't mean a little trauma. I mean big-time trauma. Like near-death experiences, you almost have to freaking die to have a near-death experience. And even then, you might not have a near-death experience. And so, when debunkers say, oh, well, you can't get that in a laboratory, therefore, it doesn't exist, I'm like, no shit. Of course, you can't get it into a laboratory. There's no trauma there. You're not killing anyone. You're not harming anyone. Thank goodness, you know. So don't go to the North Pole and tell me there are no zebras. Say, I'm at the North Pole, and guess what? There are no zebras here, but so what? There are zebras in sub-Sahara Africa. I know that. So it's all about your content. This is where a historian will kick in. It's all about the context again, and what a particular culture or context will allow, or what lives in a particular zone, and what doesn't live in another zone.
I've got a question from Stuart. He's got two questions, actually. The first one is around the Chris Bledsoe family story. How familiar are you? Yeah, you're familiar with it.
I'm very familiar with it.
Yeah. So what is your opinion of Chris Bledsoe's interpretations of the events surrounding him and his family? Do you believe in the religious interpretation or something else?
Well, I think Chris, you know, of course I know Chris, and I read UFO of God, I know the book. I think Chris is very brave in the book and that he's trying to integrate a pretty dramatic set of UFO experiences into what's essentially a conservative Christian worldview. And I think that's hard to do. So I would say I understand what Chris is doing and I admire it, but I think those those two worldviews are ultimately exclusive of one another is probably what I would say. But that's that says nothing about Chris again, that's not a condemnation or a criticism of Chris at all. It's just a reflection from someone who studies religion, you know, in a kind of comparative fashion.
I've hosted Chris and Ryan on the podcast previously, and I've been very open to see a lot of the or phenomenon I struggle with. I see a lot of posts that I believe are dust on cameras. I see a lot of posts that I believe are satellites in the sky. And I'm not saying that everything is, but I see an overwhelming amount that is, let's just say inconclusive either way, because it's a dot against a black background.
Yeah. And again, when I read a book, like UFO of God, I'm looking at the religious components, Andy. I'm not looking at whether someone's seeing a satellite or UFO. That's well outside of my expertise, okay? I'm going to believe the satellite expert or the radar expert. I'm not going to believe myself. But when I see somebody using some form of Christianity, or some form of Hinduism, or some form of Buddhism, or whatever it is, to understand their experience, then I feel like I have something to say.
The next one is a scientific question, still from Stuart, and I'm going to bastardize the pronunciation of this, but I'm sure you'll know what I mean when I say it. Do you have any thoughts or insight which can be shared on the thesis that increased connectivity between the caudate potamon, that part of the brain Gary Nolan's discussed in various, leads to a higher propensity for esoteric experience, and if so, why might this be?
Again, I'm not a brain scientist. I'm not a neuroanatomist. I'm not Gary Nolan. I just don't know. And I'm going to listen to what Gary has to say about that. I'm not going to listen to what Jeff Kreipel has to say about that. I just don't know. You know, one of the things you learn when you're a professional intellectual is you stay in your track.
Stay in your lane, yeah.
Stay in your lane. Don't, you know, every time an entertainer gets up at an award ceremony and starts talking about the environment, I'm just like, Oh, come on. I mean, stay in your lane, you know, stay in your lane. And so I'm going to stay in my lane there.
You don't want to be stinging flying around the world to tell us at a conference or award ceremony to stop boiling kettles because it's bad for the environment. I understand that. Yeah.
I'm going to stay in my lane.
Question from Mark. Many people believe that the phenomenon is already here, walking among us on earth. Assuming this is true, how do you think the general population will react? And is there risk of a witch hunt or civil unrest? Or are we unlikely to accept those entities being on us?
Yeah, so I can speak to that more broadly. I mean, I actually spoke to that at the Soul Foundation, by the way. First of all, one of my jokes is, you know, strange beings come out of the sky and mess with people. That's what we call religion. You know, this thing, this presence, whatever we want to call it, has been here a long, long time, as far back as we can see in human history, actually. So I am not of the school that this is a post-atomic bomb phenomena. I know there are people who believe that and who think that. And maybe it's gotten more cultural relevance in the Cold War, but I doubt very much it's been any more prominent in people's experience, although maybe. I'm willing to be educated there. How people will react to it? You know, even if it's been here throughout human history, it doesn't mean that human cultures that have developed are going to do well. If it shows itself, if there's some kind of disclosure, I actually don't think most cultures and most religions are capable of that. I am more on the negative side of the equation. However, I do understand what people on the positive side are saying. They're essentially saying, religion has this vertical dimension, there's something transcended to the human being, and therefore, it can incorporate some kind of disclosure event in a more efficient way. I get that, I'm fine with that. But I just think, I think whatever this thing is or whatever the nature of this presence is, it's going to mostly violate, mostly not fit in to what our assumptions are and what our beliefs are. And people, Andy, people are very bad at not identifying with their beliefs, to put it mildly. I mean, one of the things I tell my students is, please don't believe your beliefs. Please, please don't think your thoughts. Please step out of your assumptions. But that is so rare and that is so hard for people to do that. But I think that's what this thing will be about if it ever, if it ever really reveals itself in any kind of serious way.
I've had a few folks over the last couple of years, the podcast been going now three and a half years, god nearly four years next year, say to me that if we do get UFOs landing on the White House lawn, is that not the podcast finished? I was like, god no, that's when the questions begin, because that's when all the interesting conversations get to start. So for me, it's like you say, if it ever unveils itself in a true meaningful way, I think there's a whole lot more to understand.
Let me give you an example with the White House lawn comment. First of all, it assumes that the White House lawn is even significant. Yeah. Right? I mean, who says? Who says? I mean, clearly, whatever this phenomenon is doesn't give a wit about our borders or our boundaries or our cultural identities. Not one wit. It's a global phenomenon. It goes on all over the world. It's been going on for as far as we can see back. It simply doesn't care about your nation state or your culture or your religion. And that is, that to me is the spiritual revolution that we have to have. We have to go through that ourselves to see, to recognize what's actually going on here. But again, that requires a kind of comparative or global mindset that I think is fairly rare. At this point.
You mentioned two very different UFO movies earlier, Jeff, Independence Day and Arrival. Have you ever seen District 9?
I have.
I always love the beginning of any alien movie. Certain things that interest me is how they arrive, why they arrive, and like you say, communication aspect, all that kind of stuff. And the idea that it starts off with aliens land over a slum in Johannesburg, South Africa, rather than over Paris or New York or somewhere glamorous and the refugees, while they've got this incredible technology, they're suffering themselves as a civilization and they need help. And I always enjoyed that idea that it was something totally different landing somewhere totally out of the norm, which could very well be the case.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, it's been a while since I saw that movie, Andy, but that's one of, again, one of the conclusions I think one reaches if you're sit with this long enough is that it just, it's not restricted to any culture or nation state. It just isn't. I think the reporting is, and clearly the movies are made in particular cultures, but it's clearly the reception is a cultural phenomenon, but the actual phenomenon itself is global.
Yeah. If I say to you, I'm going to write a script, Jeff, and you're a Hollywood executive, and it's about an interaction between an alien spacecraft and an indigenous tribe somewhere in Northeast Asia. Okay, that's one thing, but okay, let's move that to Chicago, and it's a fight to the death between the last humans, and that's now going to sell. That's got dollars all over it. So I understand those different approaches and what works in Hollywood.
I ran a four-year conference series once on the paranormal and popular culture, and I invited all these Hollywood people to come, special effects people, directors, artists, that kind of thing. And I kept asking them, I'm like, can you make a movie about the paranormal that does not involve spandex or things blowing up? And their answer was no. And I was like, why? We have all these people who know everything about the paranormal. They can help you, but you can't just make basically people punching each other out kind of movies. And their response was, we know what sells. We know what makes money. We don't know if that'll make any money actually. And so we're not going to do it. And I was like, okay, that's an answer. That's an honest answer actually. And now I know, I don't know why the movies are so bad on this. But occasionally you'll see one that's really good on this. I'm the first to admit that. I mean, I thought Arrival was brilliant. But by the way, it's a Canadian director.
Is that why?
Well, it should tell you something right away. It's coming from outside the US for sure.
Finally, last question from Peter. Peter likes to send in a lot of questions, and I had to sift through them for this one. Peter asks, is the ontological shock argument potentially just a smoke screen to cover up misdeeds and illegalities conducted by humans?
I don't think so. I sit and talk to experiencers a lot, people who have experienced abductions, and ontological shock is a real thing. It's a real human response to something that absolutely does not fit into any model of reality they have. And to sort of force this, I mean, I think we have two instincts. If you're trained in a field like I am, you're going to reduce everything to society. You're going to say, oh, this is a function of language or culture or fantasy or science fiction or identity or politics or the social system. If you're a natural scientist, you're going to reduce everything to nature. You're going to say, oh, this is a function of physics or chemistry or matter or whatever it is, space, time. I don't think whatever this presence is, is reducible to society or nature. I think that's why it's so shocking to people, is they just can't fit it in to the water they swim in doesn't work. So, no, I don't think ontological shock is a cover or a screen. I think it's a real response, and I think it's really worth thinking with and pursuing.
Final question then for me, Jeff, is if you have to summarize what this UFO phenomenon may be, and a few sentences or less for someone coming up to you and asking, what's all this about? I've just attended the Saul Foundation because I was in the wrong room, and I heard you're talking, it was fascinating, and I was never into this alien stuff. But what's it all about? What would you say in a few sentences?
Well, are you asking me what the phenomenon is about for a conference, or are you asking me what a UFO is? What are you asking me, Andy?
So I've attended a conference by mistake, and I'm just Joe Kew public. And I wasn't into this whole alien thing, but I'm asking you as the expert I've just seen on stage in your field, you know, what is this? Is there something to it? These aren't aliens, are they? You know, that type of question.
Okay. Okay. Okay. I do have an answer. I think the extraterrestrial hypothesis is a belief system, like religion, like all kinds of religions. I don't think that these are extraterrestrials or aliens. I do think there's a real phenomenon here. I think it's also a real physical phenomenon. I think it has a physics attached to it, and I think science actually can be applied to it. But I don't think it's limited to science or to physics. So that's really my answer. Yes, it's real. No, it's not an alien. What is it? I don't think we know. If you push me and you gave me some beer, which is what I always say, I would say I think it's us. I think it's us from another space and time, actually, is what I really think. But I can't prove that, Andy. And that's not a statement that a historian of religion should make. But again, you gave me enough alcohol, and I had a weak moment, and I told you what I really thought there.
No, I appreciate that, Geoff. It's never an easy question to answer, I think, for most folks. Especially when you're a serious academic as well, but I appreciate you, and appreciate the time you've given us today as well. I would ask Geoff, just to round off, how can listeners and viewers get in touch with you, and also how can they find your work?
Well, yeah.
If you want them to get in touch with you.
Yeah. I mean, that's like, I'm not so sure I want them to get in touch with me. You can go to my website, it's jeffreyjkrpial.com, and that's a summary of all the books I've written. You can also go to impossiblearchives.org, and you can see all of the talks and all of the lectures of the two conferences there. You can, of course, write me. I mean, I'm trying to be funny, but you can write me at Rice and just write me. The problem is I can't keep up with everything, and so that's my hesitation. I mean, this took us three months to schedule, right? I mean, I'm really bad, and I'm not bad. It's just a mark of finitude. I can't do everything.
We're going to talk about today, which is extraterrestrial intelligence and the Catholic faith. Are we alone in the universe with God and the angels? My guest earned a BA in Religious Studies at Yale University and an MA and PhD in Historical Theology at Emory University. Now retired, he is serving as a professor on the faculties of several universities and colleges and as a member of the National Advisory Council of the US Conference of Catholic Bishops. My goodness, what an intro. Dr. Paul Thigpen, Paul, welcome to the podcast.
Andy, what a pleasure to be here. Thank you so much for the invitation.
It's great to have you on, and I was very aware of the dying embers of the cold I've had now for what seems like 12 years, as I read through that. So hopefully it came across okay, folks. I'm very much happy to have Paul on, someone I've been trying to get on for the last couple of months now. And I think the time in Paul has worked out really well. As we'll get to, you've recently made an appearance at the Saul Foundation's first, hopefully, annual conference, along with some huge names in the UFO conversation and some soon to be huge names in the UFO conversation as well. But I want to take things back, Paul, right to the start. And in your bio, and guests like to send over bios for themselves and say, here's some stuff that I've done as part of my career. I loved how you're finished with saying that you've had an interest in the UFO topic since you were a child, because it's always how I love to start interviews. So can we start there and go back to your very earliest memories of the UFO topic?
Sure. I was in elementary school in the early 60s. And I'm not even sure how the interest began, but when especially talk about Project Blue Book came out, other kinds of things, I read whatever capacity I could. I had a couple of dreams that may have been influenced by sci-fi movies, although I don't know how many of those were around. In fact, it was kind of a recurring dream that it was almost like the initial scenario of an abduction, but it would stop right after I'd be lying in bed, which my regular bed and my brother was in a double bed with me. And I'm lying there, there's a big window by the bed, and all of a sudden this kind of blue-green light would come down from the sky through the window and hit me and freeze me. I couldn't move. My brother remained asleep. And then the dream would always end there. So my guess is, you know, by that time, excuse me, it's probably early 60s sometime. Maybe I'd seen some movies with that kind of thing, and that's why. But it certainly helped to encourage my interest. The other thing is that when I was a teenager, I would have been senior of high school, so I would have been 17 with a couple of buddies. I grew up in Savannah, Georgia. That's where I was born. And they have islands on the coast there, Tybee Islands, the nearest to Savannah has the beaches. One evening in the summer, walking along with them on the beach. And all of a sudden, we looked up and there were two huge, what were to us, unidentified anomalous figures. They didn't look so much like craft. They looked almost like what we might describe as circular plasma. Two of them that were white but with red and green lights inside of them. And to this day, they could have been, there may be some prosaic explanation for that. I don't know. But we got scared, jumped in the car, drove back to my home about eight miles away. It seemed to follow us to the sky, maybe not disappeared. But all these things, I'm just saying, whatever they actually were, certainly continued to increase my interest. And I've never lost it.
Which is wonderful. And I wonder, was there any, how intense was your religious, or your religion, or your faith when you were a child? And did those kind of counteract each other at all?
Well, yeah, I was raised in a Presbyterian family, and interestingly enough, though, at the age of 12, one of my teachers introduced me to Voltaire, the French Enlightenment skeptic, philosopher, and some other folks like that. Reading those books, I lost my faith, and was an atheist from the age of 12 to 18. So during that time, my faith wasn't really interacting with it much. As a child, it was just kind of, where does that all fit? After I returned to faith at the age of 18, it's a whole other story to itself. Then, of course, the question was always there, if these things are real, how do they fit into my faith? And that's really the reason I wrote the book. Many years later, I became a Catholic convert. I came to the Catholic Church, and discovered there are a whole lot more resources, history, tradition about these kinds of things that could help me to try to put it all in place. So that's really, I wrote the book, and I'm coming from a particular tradition. I know there's some, you know, other religious scholars who say I can't buy into any particular story or tradition, and I'm not convinced of any particular thing. But I did come from atheism and into this faith and eventually into the Catholic faith. So I do write and think from within that frame. I know some folks who say they'll, or if you look what they do, they'll maybe religious study scholars, they'll seem like they interpret their faith, Christian Catholic, Catholic Christian, in terms of UAP studies. But I tend to do the other. For me, the primary is the Catholic faith. So I look at UAP studies through the lens of my Catholic.
That's interesting. I was going to ask as well, your family, obviously they were religious. What, if any, views did they have on the UFO topic?
As I recall, they didn't think about it much. It's not something we talked about much. I wrote a paper in maybe sixth grade or something. I've been reading maybe Kenneth Ardell's stuff or something. I don't know. I wrote a paper about it. And I may have mentioned it to them, but they were hardworking folks. We had a little family business and would come home exhausted every night, maybe watch some TV. And I don't think, like a lot of folks, it seemed like an exotic topic, I think, to them. And they probably just didn't have time to think about such things because they were worried about, how are they going to put food on the table and pay the bills?
Yeah. You're going back, you mentioned the 60s, 70s. There's no social media. People got their news from the newspapers, which was a day old, and the radio and the TV. And things are very much regionalized still, I think, back then, weren't they? That you didn't have this international stage where everyone knows everything that's happening, hundreds of thousands of miles away within seconds. Do you think if you mentioned, for example, the dreams you had back then to them, they would have just been dismissed as just silly dreams? Which I'm not saying they weren't dreams, but would they have entertained the conversation at all, or was it just silly alien talk?
Well even I myself at that point didn't think anything had really happened. It's just I would wake up. As I recall, I say I may have seen some kind of sci-fi movie or something that had an abduction. I don't know how many would have already been out by that time. We're talking about the early 60s. But as I recall, I didn't even make any kind of connection to alien abduction for a while. It just happened. I kept thinking why is the dream kept happening? Why is this dream happening? So consciously for me at least, I don't think I made any connection to it until maybe a, well, after Betty and Barney Hill story came out, and then other stories started coming out. And I would read those and began to think, wow, that sounds a lot like my dream. But I was never convinced that it actually, anything actually happened to me. Just kind of piqued my interest and somehow got into my mind.
Let's get to the point from that childhood till you wrote the book. Did you ever have any sightings or experiences yourself of any kind?
Only the thing when I was in high school that I mentioned.
Right.
And people, these days we're talking a lot about paranormal things connected. And I certainly did have paranormal experiences, but not really connected to that. I've also written books from the Catholic viewpoint about demons, demonology, that kind of thing. Had some experiences as part of what happened to me to bring me back into the faith, things that I couldn't explain otherwise. So I certainly have thought about related topics, but this one I sat on, I started doing research maybe 20 years ago, thinking I would write the book, but always written a bunch of books. There was always some other book that was more pressing, would write that. And it wasn't until the piece in 2019 in the New York Times, somehow I missed the one in 2017, I'm not sure how, but I saw that and I said, okay, this is the time to write the book I've always wanted to write. My publisher was a close friend. We were at an editorial retreat, I've been a professional editor too, on the beach at Myrtle Beach, South Carolina, and we're walking out on the beach at night and see some kind of light in the sky. I just said, you're going to think I need a tinfoil hat, but I've always wanted to write a book about extraterrestrial intelligence and the Christian faith. He said, write it, I'll publish it. That gave me encouragement because otherwise I might have had a hard time finding a publisher. But it took a couple of years to write it.
When you mention paranormal experiences and how they're not necessarily related to the UFO topic, I think more and more people are bringing themselves around to potentially there is a connection, a relationship there between the paranormal, just the normal that isn't discovered yet as such or things we don't quite yet understand. Do you think there's anything to that when we talk about the paranormal? What is the paranormal to you?
Well, yeah, there's paranormal and there's paranormal, so it means literally aside the normal, it's just outside on the perimeter of the normal. There's certain things that at least the secular world would call paranormal that as a Christian, I've believed all along, so encounters with demonic powers, even perhaps angelic, good angel kind of experiences. I was once part of, I was in a costal for a while before I was Catholic, and I was in a parish that church that was firmly convinced that it can happen, that God gives gifts to people that are beyond the normal stuff that we have. And of course, the Catholics would affirm that to a lot of saints with all kinds of things that we would now call paranormal, that God can give those gifts. And so they're beyond our nature, but still not the kind of woo that some people would think. For someone like Padre Pio, St. Pio Pietrottino, who his lifetime overlapped my own Italian mystic, what we would call the paranormal was almost normal in his life. It happened so often. So paranormal depends on where you're coming from. From a secular point of view, it often just means something anomalous or outside of the normal. From a Catholic Christian point of view, it would include things that we consider are given by God and therefore not something to puzzle over necessarily, that he can give us gifts that go beyond what we normally have. It would probably include things that are often demonically inspired. And again, I've had encounters with that all kinds. So I've written a couple of books about that. Not about my encounters, but about what the church teaches. And then there are other things that, as a Catholic Christian, I would say we have to be open to. Maybe it is something we just haven't fully understood. The whole thing with remote viewing. A lot of folks just dismiss that as they do. UAP is all demonic. But the kind of thing that some of the saints have done, the people in that parish, that church I was in, the four have done after prayer, being able to see things at a distance, know things inside of people's hearts. You can call that paranormal if you want to. But some people would say ghost and spirit, ghosts are part of the paranormal. Okay, if you want to include that. But again, for Christian, we're convinced that the soul does survive after death, that the body goes into the grave, the soul survives. One day there will be a resurrection, we receive our bodies back again. But that in the meantime, that departed, that human spirit that is no longer connected to its earthly body is what we would call a ghost. And that's all through our traditions in the scripture. It's in all kinds of stories of the saints where they encounter people who have died because God gave them a reason to come back for some reason to interact with the living. So none of that is, you know, once I came to the place of firm Catholic faith, so much of what we consider paranormal was not unbelievable to me.
And again, I'll state, I've said this many times on the podcast and it's not a cop out, but I'm not religious in the slightest. So I've got a very, very broad, generic view of religions and, you know, what I can pick up here and there. And I've always said each to their own. There's none of them, I particularly believe. I've probably got a view that you hear quite often that I imagine is probably in some way wrong, but that most religions are based on something that has a basis thousands of years ago. So they're all very much variations of a theme. I get all religions have their own deities, but some of them overlap and various gods and prophets overlap across religions. But I think generally there's a lot of patterns I can see that make sense, that regardless what religion you believe in, or if you even include your faith in the UFO topic or what you believe in UFOs, the idea that we are connected in some way, that what our soul is, where you go when you die, are you part of a greater consciousness? Is this an experience you have? And it still just seems like a variation on a theme and that UFOs in a way is just a whole other religion itself. Can you talk on that? Where am I right? Where am I wrong?
Yeah. Well, it's... Where do I start? I think in one way, one reason that what we would normally call religion, why they have these themes and you see patterns, is that although they're all pretty much asking the same questions and their faith, their religion gives an answer to those questions. So some of the questions would be, how did the universe come to be? How did we come to be? And how did I come to be? Is there a purpose in life? Is there something beyond matter, energy, and force, force fields? Fields. What, you know, what, how do you know right from wrong? Those are all kind of, I used to teach a comparative religion courses in college. And those are the kind of questions that prompt religious answers. And so, so I'd agree they're trying to answer the same questions. I would say if you look at the whole spectrum though, you may have some overlapping experience and certainly in the moral area. But the basic tenets can be really, really different. You know, all the way from the Greek pantheon of Greek gods, none of whom are all powerful or all knowing, but more kind of like elevated humans. To the sense that the Christians and Jews and Muslims would say there's one, one God who created everything out of nothing. That's, you know, it's really different. You do have, and one of the things I used to point my course is that, and pretty much as far as I know, there may be some I don't know about. Although what we call the primal or at least the traditional religious, religious traditions, the older forms of them, including the primal religions, which would be original Native American, indigenous African, and that kind of thing, and European, that you do run into conviction that evil spirits exist. That's one of the things that I began to see, you know, maybe there is something to this evil spirits that they may disagree all these religions on God and all kinds of other things, but it's amazing unless you look at some modern version that's been trying to demythologize, so to speak, the traditional versions of all these religions, I'll say, yeah, there's something out there that's malicious, that's not corporeal, that, you know, can come after us. So plenty of overlap in those things, and again, immorality to a lot of, to a great extent. But the most important issues, I think, tend to be different. So for instance, you know, as a Christian, I would push back some on the idea that's becoming popular in UFO circles, that there's a kind of impersonal consciousness that the universe has arisen from somehow, and that we are all part of that consciousness. I would say, you know, as a Christian, I believe that there is a personal God. He's personal, he's rational intellect, he has a free will, he loves, and that he alone is self-existent, and that everything that is, he created out of nothing, and he created it in love. This is part of what I was talking about in the Soul Foundation Symposium, that he loves us, that we're broken, we need healing, he wants us to be healed. But even when you look at those major things, that still leaves a lot of room for mystery and other kinds of things, other creatures out there like that. But it is different, it's not the notion that we're all part of a great consciousness or that the consciousness is part of the universe. It is that he's a personal God, he's not like the force of Star Wars. He's a personal God, loves, thinks all those things, and he creates out of nothing. So his creation is utterly different from him, and yet he is utterly present to his creation in every way. And because of that, then he's able to do all kinds of things for us, whether it's spiritual gifts that allow us to see things at a distance or to know the future with prophecy. So yeah, I don't know if that's answering your question or not.
No, no, it does. Yeah. And like I say, I don't think anyone could ever come on the podcast and convert me to a religion. I think I'm well past that now at 37 years of age, and no one's ever tried, which is wonderful. Like I say, each to their own, because I know certainly when I go to work and work in an office or entertain anyone on the UFO conversation, it very quickly gets the eye rolls and tuts and little green men conversation. And I imagine anyone of any faith or religion ends up in those same conversations as well. And that's what I think the UFO or religious conversations can be very similar in a lot of ways as well. A few different ways I could take what you said, Paul. I want to bring it back to this first because I think I'm going to come back to some of the things you mentioned there in a short while. So I heard you discuss on another podcast, it might have been about a year ago. I think it was a year ago, Pints with Aquinas. Yes. I'll put the link in the description. It was a three hour conversation, really interesting. It goes back and forward between religion UFOs. I mean, that guy knew what he was talking about. And I'm guessing that was a podcast on religion, but you just happened to be discussing your book. So really interesting conversation. Some of it way over my head, other parts of it really interesting. You mentioned on it, though, Paul, that the UFO topic as a civilization was taken very seriously by us humans, going back around 26 centuries. Ancient writers, ancient philosophers all entertained it. And it only seems to be when the US government got involved in the 1940s, we're talking Roswell, you know, atomic bombs and whatnot, that it took a turn. And now people look down on or dismiss the topic, and there's a real fight to bring that back around. And I wonder, first off, why do you think religion now seems to be something that's so powerful world wide still, as it has been through the centuries, has never had such a knock like that, yet the UFO topic seemed to go the other way so quickly?
Well, I mean, you know, a couple of things. And that is more than half of the book, the first part is about what I call the history of the conversation. So starting with the ancient Greeks and the Romans, before the Christian era, we already had folks talking about these things seriously. And then the early Church Fathers we call them the great writers and thinkers of the first few centuries of the Church. Most of them were very well versed in the Roman and Greek philosophers. And so the questions kind of came to them. And so it is important, yes, to affirm that this conversation was taken very seriously. I say an introduction of my book, if you want to give me a tinfoil hat, we could have to give it to a lot of other people too, everybody from Plato to Aristotle, Aquinas and Augustine, and Benjamin Franklin, and on and on, Thomas Paine. So, but if you look at it, and you can see in the book, the conversation is very lively, all the way through the Middle Ages, all the way through the Renaissance, into the modern era, into the 19th century, the 1800s. And then finally, kind of around 1950, with Sputnik, the beginning of the space age, you had especially among Catholic theologians, a lot of talk about it, because a lot of people were thinking about skies. But it was soon after that, within the next generation of theologians, but not just theologians, scientists as well, no one would talk about it. And we have the documents that have been brought out because of the FOIA, the Freedom of Information Act, demonstrating that the intelligence community and the Department of Defense, it was part of their intention to subject the subject to ridicule, to work with their, what shall I say? It looks like plants. But the folks in the legacy media who will cooperate with them, to turn this into a subject of mockery. And even though they couldn't keep it a secret, there have been plenty of whistleblowers. But most of them were dismissed. That's what they were able to do, is to make them look foolish. So that seems to be what happened with theologians as well as with scientists, that they mostly want to stop talking about it. And that's such a shame. It means that we talk about anomalous phenomena. Well, we are the anomaly, our generation is the anomaly. Historically, the norm was to talk about the subject very seriously and take different positions. Our generation has been the anomaly and it's time we get back to taking it seriously.
Why do you think so many folks world wide? And I would say, generally, there's a far bigger audience that is more comfortable having a conversation about gods, regardless of your religion and prophets, stories from the Bible, the Koran, various different religious texts are far more comfortable with those conversations. And there's far less ridicule than there is about the UFO topic. Why do you think that is? Because again, as somebody who isn't religious, I look and go, and I don't mean to downplay this, but man in the sky, up in the clouds where God isn't in the clouds, I get that. But mythical being up there creates the earth in seven days, however you want to play that Noah's Ark, all these stories that people take so literally. And then you've got the UFO topic, topic where you just have to look at it and go, for someone like me trying to have that conversation with someone else, why couldn't something have evolved ever so slightly before us? And it's a couple of hundred or a couple of thousand years more advanced than it is, if not more. And it came here from some place else, it's been here before, et cetera, and set your own ending. I don't see why the conversations are so different, yet they still seem to be.
Yeah, that's a good question. I think there's several things. One is that, because I've often thought the same thing, the kind of classical Christian imagination, Catholic and otherwise, has room for all the stuff, because we've got room for God, for angels and demons, and so-called paranormal phenomena that we understand is something from God, that you know what happens unless it's demonic. But, so why is that? And the answer I've come to is that, where do I start? First of all, there are a lot of folks who believe that if something's not in scripture, clearly in scripture, that it can't be true, can't be real. And of course, that's easily responded to. I'll say, well, the scripture doesn't talk about dinosaurs or duck-billed platypi or microbes or molecules, but we know they exist. So it's not intended to be an exhaustive encyclopedia of everything that exists. The thing I'm finding is that there's a lot of, I just have to use the word ignorance. I don't mean it in a bad way. It just means lack of knowledge, lack of understanding about the Christian tradition itself. People are totally surprised when they find out that very well-respected figures in the Christian, especially Catholic tradition for centuries, have talked about this seriously and some of them even posit it. Yes, there's intelligent life and if not that, they're at least open about it. They don't seem to understand that's part of our tradition. That's somehow been eclipsed, in part because of the modern intellectual movement, beginning with the Enlightenment, away from anything considered supernatural to it has to be scientific. So that, I guess the church Christians have been almost as much affected in certain ways by the culture of scientism that if science can't explain something, it doesn't exist, as others have. And that's a shame because again, their religion should push back against that. That one of my hopes is that in this conversation, as more and more people who've kind of believed only in what science can show them, begin to realize looking at this topic, there are things out there that can't be measured, that science doesn't seem to have a hold on, that we can say, that's right. Let's talk about that because that's part of what we understand about the world. Don't know if I'm answering your question, but I do think, yeah, part of it was that there was not in scripture the other. It's a very human thing, I find, is that for a lot of people, if something they don't understand something and they don't like it, it makes them uncomfortable, then they just write it off as demons or in some cases, government psyops. There's not a lot of depth and thinking in that regard. It's a reaction. I understand it. I mean, this not everybody has time to read my book with 40 pages and five or 50 footnotes, but it's lamentable, I think, too. I mean, it's the same, like you said, it's the same kind of reaction you get sometimes by scientists. They don't understand it, but they know science doesn't account for it, so they have to write it off as something they do understand. Hallucination, mental illness, aerial phenomena of prosaic nature. And I think religious people tend to sometimes do the same thing. They don't understand it, makes them uncomfortable. It's outside the box. How can I give it a cause that does fit into my religious world? It's an easy out.
I think the big thing that is missing for me, and again, just for anyone listening to this might think otherwise. Paul, you've written a book here for the UFO topic, you know, for how it has its place in Catholic faith, how they can mirror, how they can merge and answers and talks about some of those questions. And that's the way you're coming at this, which is great. It's not me having a guest on and arguing with them, you know, about their viewpoint compared to mine. But I'm giving you some of my frustrations, and I'm sure there's a record by other folks out there as well. Evidence is always thrown at folks when we talk about the UFO topic. Where's the evidence? What's the evidence? And you can show folks any number of videos. They're dismissed as X, Y, or Z. But you can talk about your own experiences, and then any number of sightings, reportings. And like you say, when it comes to religion, it seems very much that the evidence, like you say, is in scripture. So if it's not in this book or written down, then it never happened. A lot of folks, however, tend to say that there's quite a lot across various religions that do or does reference the UFO topic. And I wonder, can you talk a little bit about that? What are some of the main, and you mentioned it in the book, but what are some of the key figures or prominent members of the Catholic faith over the centuries who have had some kind of either experience or talked about the UFO topic?
The, I guess the kind of the basic thing we have to see here is that early Christians up until the Middle Ages were deeply influenced by the philosophy of the ancient Greeks, Plato first and then Aristotle by way of St. Thomas Aquinas. And Aristotle's view of the Cosmos in particular did not allow for anything like this in the sense that thought that the earth was the center of the universe. And then the kind of the realm that was concentric circles in the moon, the sun, the stars. And did not even conceive of a kind of, of any kind of rocky balls like our planet that could actually have creatures on them. The moon was the exception. I think even Aristotle may have briefly considered the possibility that there could be life on the moon. The closest they got to it was this notion that, that the stars were actually animated creatures. They had souls. And so the soul moved what we saw physically of the star around the heavens. So in that sense, I mean, that's basically a form of extra trust in intelligence that they did allow for. But for the most part, they didn't even have a notion. But they knew of the planets in the sky, but the whole, the word planet in Greek means wanderer. They just thought that they were stars that weren't moving around the sky with the rest of the stars. So all that's to say that it took a while for, it wasn't really until the time of Copernicus. He comes along and then with Galileo and others begins to demonstrate, we're really not the center of everything. And you get Christians waking up and saying, well, you know what? That never was part of our religion. Really, it's not in the Bible. It comes from this pre-Christian philosophy. We can give that up and still account for all these things. And so at that time, then you begin to have people like Nicholas of Cusa. He was a really big figure of the 16th century church. He not only was a cardinal, but he was a papal legate, a papal advisor, was a part of the Ecumenical Council, a great council of Basel. And he wrote openly about this and about how he thought there probably is intelligent life. He speculated about what kinds of other planets out there. Later on, you get people like a highly respected Catholic visionary, Blessed Anne Catherine Emmerich, German, who in her vision sees intelligent life out there. You get people like Padre Pio, St. Pio Petrottino, I think I mentioned him before, his life overlapped mine. And he was given to all kinds of visionary things and healing miracles and what Catholics call bilocation, where his body would be in one place and his soul in the other. And again, it's not legendary. It was the same time as my lifetime, overlapping plenty of documentation of that. But he in particular once was asked in an interview, what do you think about aliens? And he said, he was just like, he always was very direct. What? You think God didn't create any other creatures like us? You think we're the only ones that go, glory to God, and he actually said that there were creatures on other planets who had not fallen, who had not been morally broken the way we are. So you get folks like that. You get St. John Paul II, Pope John Paul II, who once was asked publicly by a girl in the audience at a parish in Rome, what about aliens? He didn't say, well, that's contrary to the Catholic faith. He didn't say, we don't know. He didn't say any of that stuff. He said very affirmatively, always remember, they are God's children too. So that's powerful to me. But even if you go back, so that's the more modern stuff. But even if you go back to before those times, what you do get are affirmations of the possibility or even affirmations of the existence of other kinds of non-human intelligence besides angels. You get that in St. Augustine, the greatest theologians the Church ever had. You get in St. Jerome, who was considered the father of biblical scholarship both in the 4th century. And they talked about some of the Greek philosophical, not philosophical, Greek mythological figures as if they were real creatures of some kind that we didn't know fully about. But that they were not angels and they were not humans. And St. Jerome in particular makes it really clear. I'm not just repeating the story that I heard. This is, you know, things happened in just a short time ago where one of these things was captured and brought before the emperor. So all that to say there, you've got all kinds of figures like that. You've got plenty of Christians more recently, since the 20th century, that have openly talked about it and affirmed at least the possibility. But so part of that was just to, what I'd love to help other Christians do is to say, we need to recover these aspects of our own tradition that do allow for this, and some that even affirm it. And the kind of characters that Jerome and Augustine talked about are what we might now call ultra terrestrial. Something else that shares the planet with us. It's been here a long time. So even though they weren't talking about ETI, extraterrestrial, because they didn't have a notion of planets out there, Augustine was open to the idea, Aquinas was open to the idea of the stars being animated. But then even the early guys were saying, yeah, I think there are other things besides humans and angels right here on planet Earth and have them. And I think it's important for us to realize that this is the big phenomena, we tend to lump it all together, but I think it's a bunch of things. I think it's probably almost certainly some of it's extraterrestrial, but I think some of it may be ultra-terrestrial. Some of it could be angelic. I do think some of it's demonic, and the people who criticize my work most from within the church are ones who say it's all demonic. And I don't think you can make that absolute claim at all. A lot of the things just don't fit the profile. I know the profile of demonic, diabolical possession in other cases, and most of it doesn't fit that. Maybe some of the abduction scenarios too, but so I can see it overlap. But anyway, it's just not all the same thing. I don't think at all.
I'm a bit scared of demonic stuff, ghost stuff. I said, I got that. I sound so professional, don't have demonic stuff and ghost stuff. They've always scared me since being a kid. I've never liked even like horror movies. I wish I liked horror movies and supernatural films. I struggled to watch them without jumping constantly. But I did take myself recently to see the New Exorcist movie. And again, there's an exorcism performed, the idea of two young children being possessed. I find all that really scary and just the idea that these things happen, they have happened within the churches and the Vatican's involvement or non-involvement and whatnot in some of these stories is kind of fascinating and scary. But like you say, sometimes you look at that. And as I watched that movie, just for that moment, I thought, the UFO lens and is that really related to what's happening here? It just seems such a stretch. But like you say, it's all still labels being put on something we don't fully understand, or maybe we did understand better some time ago and understand less now, or we just don't entertain the notion, especially in the Western world. I think there are parts of society and parts of the world that still have a far greater spiritual connection to whatever may have come before us or may be interacting with us. But I wonder, you mentioned those labels, angels, demons, angelic, demonic, is the problem that they're just being labeled and almost the commercial idea we have of these things now. When someone says angel, you think robed figure, long hair, wings on their back, and then demon as Dave Grohl in the Tenacious D video, big horns, all red, devil-like. Is that the problem that we think of them to boxed in?
Well, one thing about the Catholic faith is that what they believe that they can define, what's been revealed by God, they're very careful to define, and then they leave open a lot of stuff for mystery. And so obviously, there's still a lot to understand about angels, both the good ones and the fallen ones, the demons. But the Catholic understanding, and I fully agree, is that they were a race, they are an intelligent race, also created by God, created good, before the human race was created, and that some of them turned against God, in rebellion, and then became corrupted in their mind and will. And that they are still allowed to roam, and they come on earth, and they hate us because we're sons and daughters of God, we're in the image of God, and they want to deface us, they want to bring us to hell with themselves. And so, in the Catholic tradition anyway, it's very clear what they are. We know they had a beginning, we know that you have good ones and ones that have fallen, we know that they're non-caporial, they don't move through space, they don't have bodies the way we do, the pure spirit. We know that they know a whole lot more than we do, they've got gifts and powers beyond us. We know that they do get involved in things on Earth. But we also know, and it's part of our faith, that one of the things that Jesus Christ came to do was to conquer that. He has authority as God in the flesh, he has authority over them. That's one of the things, the Catholic tradition when you begin to bump up of these things that you can make use of that, to find out whether something is demonic or not. If you have an experience like that, you can, again, I've been in fault in exorcisms, I've been consulted in cases of debilical possession, and the sacraments of the church, the sacraments, rituals of the church, the name of Jesus, Scripture, if they're truly demonic, they respond to that, and they have to submit to the authority. It may take a while if they resist, but I know this sounds crazy to a lot of your listeners, but it's true, believe me, I've seen this stuff physically myself, I mean, personally myself. You can discern that, and what you find is, in the history of exorcism even, then you have people who report things that looked demonic, they're not really malicious, but poltergeist stuff. The church is brought in to make the things submit and leave in the name of Jesus, and they don't respond at all. They don't seem to respond in any of the ways that demons do, and they seem to be more prankster than destructive. And that's one reason, I wrote about that in my book too, that's one of the reasons why I think you can see that, St. Augustine talked about, you can see that as possible evidence that there are on earth other creatures, also with free will and intellect, who may or may not be fallen as we are, but that they're not demons. If they were demons, then we have experience with demons, we know what to do with them, if you have the authority. Is that making sense?
No, yeah, it does. Even the earlier part of what you were saying, though, when you say, you know, there is a god and he is and that's capital H, I think there's a lot of like Tom DeLong, again, God, this makes me sound younger than I am probably, but what Tom DeLong says, you're familiar with Tom DeLong, I take it. And yeah, what he said, yeah, I'm just assuming. But when he's talked about, there's a battle for our souls. And there are entities that are jealous that we have free will, that, you know, we are here. And some of these entities or intelligences want to see us prosper. Some are just kind of nonplussed and others want to see us cannot be negative. They live off a fear. And a lot of that sounds very similar to what you were saying previously. And that's where I look at so much of those stories, as I view them, overlap, because if you just change the odd word here and there, then you're looking at a phenomenon. Take a label off instead of angel or demon, say gray, say, I don't know what to say, mantis being, I think, yeah, that's another conversation for another day. But a non-human intelligence, it substitutes in, doesn't it?
Well, in the sense that people with similar experiences, you know, have different names for different understandings of what they are. And again, you know, from the Catholic tradition, I would say that whatever else there might be out there, that we would affirm that there are angels created before us, created good, some of them fell, they're demonic. And then that kind of battle for our souls, as Tom would describe it, is going on specifically with them. But we wouldn't, I don't know that we would say that, and that's equivalent to X, Y or Z, maybe something different. Maybe, in some cases, the religious traditions, like I mentioned before about all the older traditions, talk about evil spirits. So they seem to be speaking out of experience. So if the experience is similar, then of course, they're going to talk about it and they'll have different names for it and different understandings. So to that extent, sure, I think there's a common experience of certain things across religions. And from the Catholic point of view, I'd say, and at least some of them we can define. But there's room for a lot of mystery.
Oh, there's a lot of wiggle room in this. And this is something I'm going to mention, Paul. This isn't something I want you to answer because you couldn't. No one could. This is just where my brain goes when you're saying what you're saying. OK, for listeners who wonder what I struggle with inside with some of these conversations, you know, when someone like yourself talks about exorcism, demonic possession, which I believe does happen as much as I hate watching movies about it, you then think of the UFO topic. And if we have got beings coming here from somewhere else, whatever that may look like, you start to get into the realms of if, if indeed both of those things are true, then how does that work? Could another being that wasn't us be possessed by something demonic? And, you know, my head just goes to really strange places with that kind of stuff. And it's a conversation for a whole other time, if it could even be had, Paul. I want to keep it a little bit more grounded still, if I can. And a belief I had when I started the podcast, I think is very, very base amongst many people, is that if we got confirmation tomorrow, the old capital D disclosure, we have an alien race visiting us, we have crashed craft, crashed bodies recovered, et cetera, et cetera, that worldwide religions would collapse and it would lead to chaos. And I think when I speak to friends, family, general public on the topic, that still comes up quite early on in the conversation. That's something the more folks I've spoken to of various different religions and faiths, more and more I've came away from that whole idea because the religious minded folks seem to be the most accepting of this. Is that fair?
For the most part, yeah. And so for instance, the Vatican, you talk to the Vatican is a big thing. So you talk to individuals, but certainly folks like the Vatican astronomers, the observatories that they have are open to talking about these things. And in many ways, even folks like Ross Coulthard has said he's found Catholic figures to be probably the most open to all of this. So I think that's true for a lot of folks. You do have segments though of religious populations that again are reacting to the whole thing is uncomfortable. I don't like it. I don't understand it. So it's all demons. It's not me. I'm already, you know, experiencing that a lot. I'll get a push back from certain kinds of Christians and Catholics who just, it's all demons. You're leading people to hell by even saying, this is possible, that kind of thing. And they will have a hard time, you know, if that comes up, although they already kind of have some of them a fallback position that, okay, even if the government comes out and discloses, it's all a red flag. It's all a, I mean, a false flag operation. It's government PsyOps. They've worked out this entire mythology, modern mythology of hell. So what will happen is the government will come out, say it's real, it's a threat. So we need to unite with other governments of the world and have a one world government in order to fight the threat. And then that's gonna set things up for Antichrist to come, you know, possess the world. So they've already kind of worked that out. You have all these fallback positions. Well, even if the government says that, okay, well, what if, you know, we see them flying over the White House or wherever, it doesn't have to be the White House, it could be the Kremlin, it could be all kinds of places. Say, oh no, that's, what is it? Project Blue Beam or something like that. That's all holograms. They figured out all these ways, just like folks who, you know, don't believe in the moon landing or the Earth is flat. They've got all these fallback positions until finally you get to a place where the statements they're making are non-falsifiable. What are you gonna say to falsify? Because they'll always have something else. So what I'm saying is within the community, I think they'll plead plenty of religious people. The surveys that have been done by sociologists all seem to point in that way that most of the folks will be fine. But the ones that have already decided, and was what Catholic theology, moral theology would call a rash judgment without having all the facts, that have already decided it's all demonic, they'll have a hard time.
I wonder how does someone like yourself argue or help the argument that within the US government there are individuals, organizations who are very religious and given their beliefs this is entirely demonic. That's why they are very much against this coming out. They want to keep it secret. And they very much believe, you know, Old Testament type stuff. How do you try and rationalize that conversation for these folks to say that... How do we move it forward? Let me just leave it there.
Well, that's one of the reasons I wrote the book. To be able to say, okay, to understand that, you know, you're actually... It's all demonic, all that kind of... Because you don't understand it, and some of it feels threatening. Let's go back and recover elements of the Christian tradition that you may not be aware of. So that you see that this is not something people have feared for 2,000 years as Christians. But that they've talked about rashly and openly in some disagreements. But that it's only been since the 40s and 50s when the government started getting involved that we developed this attitude of fear and all that kind of thing. You try to help them to see, and this is part of what my talk, the Seoul Symposium was, help them to see that it really doesn't overthrow their faith as it stands. It would lead to lots of questions and you'd have to imagine more things than they've ever imagined before. But the foundations are still secure. We can account for this the same way we accounted for the Copernican Revolution, because that change wasn't really part of the faith, but it did open up all kinds of possibilities. The problem is most of the folks I know who react that way are willing to read a book like the one I have, corresponded with some of them that I know personally. And they'll say, no, I'm not going to read the book, I'm not even going to talk to you. I'm 100 percent convinced of this. What you're doing is you're leading people to demons, that kind of stuff, I don't want to talk about it. And so I'm not sure how to help those people except to pray for. But for ones who are willing to say, okay, let me at least see another side to this. I'd say read my book, just read history.
I wouldn't pray for them, I'll judge them silently and make passive aggressive comments on social media. But yeah, whatever works for folks, I'm sure it all has the same effect. Paul, you mentioned your talk at the Saul Foundation event. Let's talk about that. That was going back to the middle of November now. We're recording this right at the end of December, folks. How was that experience for you? I'm very much hoping to be at the next one, not as a speaker for the love of God, you would never have that unless they go right downhill, Gary Nolen and Peter Scafish. But I'd love to be there as part of that audience. But yeah, tell us about the experience in your talk.
Oh, Andy was wonderful. First of all, I felt very honored to be there. You mentioned all those great, well-known speakers that here I am being asked to say, nobody knows me, what's... But it says a lot about Peter and Gary, who are organizing it. Did they...
Let me say, Paul, and I never interrupt, but that was my point I made earlier, that I think I said in the introduction, it had names that we know, and also names that we don't yet know. And I think that's the point. This isn't awakening or contact in the desert, which is look at all these names and buy tickets to see them. Not that that's a bad thing, but this was an event for religious folks, academic folks, scientifically minded folks, military folks, to get together and have a conversation from different aspects of it. And it didn't matter if you were, you'd sold one book or never written a book, but your talk was relevant and had a purpose. Or if you're at the top of the food chain and you literally had luck to hang a door to the saucers, you know, it seemed that that was the point of it. And that's why I love the idea about it. So sorry to interrupt, but that's why I think it was great folks like yourself for there because it's very much needed as part of this conversation.
Well, Peter and Gary, again, were, I mean, you even read the mission statement of soul and they want to bring together kind of serious academics, but also policy advisors and all kinds of folks to talk about it in a serious way. And they recognize that, especially if part of what they want to do is kind of help prepare the world for the possible disclosure. If you're going to help people prepare for that, the religious communities are a big part of that. I mean, Catholics alone are an estimated 1.3 billion people on the planet. And so they recognize that we've got to have theologians at the table. That's something that Lewell and Zando has said repeatedly, said it to me as well. But he said it publicly that if you're going to have people discussing this, you've got to have folks involved in that in some way too. So that really reflects their breath of vision, that they would invite me. They had Jeff Kripal you've already had on, Dinah Pesulka, others to talk about religion, but other kinds of things, feels. And then they would also invite me, because other folks from this position kind of, I don't sign on to any of these beliefs or to any particular religion and kind of take in a distance is just fine. But they knew from my book what I wanted to do, and that was, okay, if we're concerned about helping people to accommodate this within the parameters of traditional faith, what would it be like to have one person do it for a particular faith? How about pretty much the largest organizational, you know, organization in the world? And so they invited me and they knew that some of the things I would say were going to be different from what some of the other speakers touch on our religion would be. But that was fine. And so just kudos to them for even thinking of it, going to all the trouble to do it. When I got there, things started on Friday mornings, Friday and Saturday. Thursday evening, though, they had speakers and some other people invited to just wine reception. And immediately, I just felt at home, I don't know how else to put it. All these folks were there, coming at it from different directions. But you had the sense, number one, there was a sense of kind of solidarity there, and that we've all got the same intense interest. And number two, that we're all seeking the truth, you know, that there really is some kind of truth to this, and each of us is coming at it from our own direction. But the other thing is that you could have a conversation about these matters without worrying, is the other person going to think I need a tin foil hat? Because they're all coming to the phone. And each one of them, you know, they have their own experiences of how they've been rejected by friends or people who've read their stuff or whatever. But they were open-minded, they were friendly, they were, since even more than solidarity, maybe a sense of camaraderie that was there. I enjoyed it thoroughly. And not only were the talks just amazing, but the, as you might expect, the conversation is outside of the talks, not just among the speakers, but other attendees. And so, you know, sitting down, sitting down having dinner with, or a table with folks I've heard about all my life, not all my life, but all my interest in UFO, and just hear them tell kind of stories behind the scenes about their experiences. And it was wonderful. It's just wonderful. And I met people. The other good thing about the conference, that has been talked about much is that at that dinner table, one of the persons there had been one of those who helped choose out of all the many people who applied, who would come. And that there was, they intentionally wanted the attendees to have very different backgrounds and interests, diversity there. And that made for a really interesting audience and for conversations outside. So, you know, my first lunch, I sat down and someone sits down next to me and says, can we talk? I said, I'd love to talk, introduce. And he's from Tokyo and he flown in from Tokyo to do this. Had a great interest in this, but he wasn't professionally anything connected with it. But then he read some of my books on demonology and wanted me to autograph them. And that was just the beginning. So many different people, interesting, all there because they have an interest in it. So I just really appreciate the folks with the symposium wanting to have that kind of diversity in the audience as well as in the speakers. But I learned so much. Oh, I learned so much. Oh my goodness.
I love that. You see the diversity in the conversation. I spoke to someone a while back who was organizing an event, and they told me that the event that was coming up, and no sleight on them at all from this, what they were looking to move into more of a mix of military and academic science, religion, and very much what Saul was, and when their event was announced last year, it was the same 12 star seed ascension folks. And I was like, so yeah, and each to their own, people will listen to this and watch this. Thanks for doing that. I really appreciate it. But they enjoy that side of the conversation, and that's wonderful. There's aspects of it I like, there's some of it I don't like, there's some of it I just don't understand or want to understand enough depending on my own beliefs in the UFO topic. But I think Saul seemed to really grab that dynamic and that overall arch of what this topic has to be going forward to really grab the mainstream. I'd say to get your, just before we go into listening to questions, Paul, the one person this year above anyone else even who did grab true worldwide attention and headlines was David Grush. I don't think it's even close given what he has done since July when he came out of those hearings. In the UFO conversation, it's been huge in that impact. I think I've based that and I've said before, Paul, on how far reaching his comments were because it really hit home in the UK for, albeit a very short candle. It made an impact here in our news, which is rare. I wonder what are your thoughts on what David Grush came out and said over the course of those kind of few months, but also what was the general conversation like again, from your peers and colleagues who maybe were dismissive of the topic, but then hear David Grush saying what he said.
Yeah, first of all, I think Thedae is a hero, very courageous man. I find him completely credible. Have I had the pleasure of meeting him yet? I was hoping he would be at the conference. He was only able to speak by Zoom, but I do find him credible, and I know people well who know him well and who say he's a man of integrity. And to be honest, if you've been in this subject, you're studying it for any time, there's hardly anything that he said, well, there's a little bit of what he said that was new, but mostly it was just things he said. Well, yeah, thank you for saying that because we've been saying that for years and are thinking that's possible for years. So, he did so much to open up things. He's obviously had some more interviews after all that, and he's beginning to say more. So, I'm very glad he did what he did. I've had people ask me in podcasts, some of the things, you know, what I think about him. Of course, with the one thing he did talk about that maybe I shouldn't even bring it up, but was his claim that the Vatican knew about a crash in 1933 in Medina, Italy, near Milan.
Yeah.
And then that in 1944, when the Mussolini government was collapsing, the Pope Pius XII was a liaison for the United States government to get it out of there before that other hands, apparently. And, you know, folks will ask me that. And I'll say, well, this obviously from where I am, I can't say this for sure, but it really would not surprise me. I see it as something that's certainly possible. If I put myself in that position, if it happened, I can imagine being put by the 12th say, okay, Mussolini government has fallen. Things are chaotic here. The Germans have been known to be interested in this stuff and they're spiriting things off to South America, whatever. The Russians are definitely interested in this. They keep advancing. The mafia may even be interested in possessing it and selling it to the highest bidder. What should I do? You know, not that he was in possession of it, but it would make sense to say, okay, of all the possibilities, probably should see if the United States would take it before it gets in the wrong hands. That's just all my speculation. But all that to say, I think it's certainly possible that folks I've talked to, there were people with whatever was revealed several decades ago publicly had problems with that, saying, well, the documentation stuff is so flimsy and all kinds of things. And even then I was saying, okay, if that's all we've got, it's probably really dubious. But if Grush actually has access to other materials that the public hasn't had, that have convinced him, then that would be a different matter. And I've come to believe that that is the case, that he has other stuff that the public doesn't have access to yet. So all this to say, yes, I think it could be, that's the only claim that he made, that really in the beginning just took me back and said, oh really, tell me about that. So I don't know if it's answering your question or not, but that did change the conversation. So as far as the believability, that's the other thing you mentioned. The folks who have pushed back saying, it's all demons. The second part of that argument is, it's all demons or government PSYOPs. And so you have folks, their fallback position as well. Yeah, he said all that, but he's just part of the government's false flag operation. And how do you argue with that? I mean, you can say, okay, you've got hundreds of thousands of these reports all over the world. People have nothing to do with the United States government. How can you say that's all government PSYOPs? But then they fall back on the demons arguments.
Let me ask you on that. You mentioned obviously the Pope who was involved in that potential crash recovery or alleged crash recovery from the 30s, 40s, the Middle East government. I can see why the head of a church of 1.3, 1.4 billion people would have a say in that secrecy because that changes a whole conversation for a whole section, if not the entire planet. I wonder if next week, let's say President A or Prime Minister B or whoever it may be in charge of a country or a superpower comes out and confirms here's the body of an alien being that we recovered in a crash recently, and here's a crashed craft. It's time to acknowledge this is true, this is real, and there's something here that's not human. What do you think immediately happens in terms of the Catholic Church? What would the Pope come out and say, do you think?
Well, I'll start off with what I don't think he would say is, oh, it's all demonic. I really don't. Yeah, I think, you know, just looking at the history of the Vatican and how they operate, it's always very slowly and it's very carefully. Either they would not say anything or they might say something like, well, we have to leave all this up to science. Or, I think there's a possibility they could say, yes, yes, we affirm that that's true. But the one thing I don't think they would say is it's all demons.
What do you think the reaction would be then, as someone of that faith? What would you react? Well, your reaction is probably quite obvious, given what you're doing now in your involvement in the UFO topic. But what's the average, you know, person of faith's reaction to that, do you think?
Probably, there are a lot of folks I've met that have said, you know, if that happened tomorrow, it wouldn't disturb me because I've just got to put food on the table and pay the bills. So for them, a lot of folks is just, oh, okay, yeah, I grew up on Star Wars. That's not a big deal. For others, it would be, you know, know personally of someone who was in a position to, his very faithful Catholic and active in ministry and was in a position to witness things that made it really clear if there was something going on that was not human. And it threw him into turmoil. So how does my faith account for this? And then it turns out he read my book and then got in touch with me and said, thank you for writing it. It's point by point, you answer my questions. I'm at peace now. It's okay. So I think there will probably be a lot of folks like that. They would say, wow, how does this fit into my faith? What does this mean now? In which case, I'd be saying to a lot of pastors, do you need to read my book? So you can answer their questions. But then there would be the others, just convinced themselves it's all demonic, who would either say it's all government psyops or even if they were bodies, they would say it's some kind of demonic thing. It's interesting, back when the evolution became something talked about and accepted by the scientific community, and there were certain Christians that just fully resisted that for various reasons. The Catholic Church allows for that, it's no problem. But when they began to discover, archaeologists began to dig and discover dinosaur skeletons and things like that, then people would say, okay, this does so, things are very old. The earth is very old and this is back there. You actually had some Christians, I don't know if they're any Catholics or not, but who said, no, actually those were created by demons and put in the earth, so they would trip over our faith. I could imagine some people having a similar reaction now that, oh, you've got a body. Well, okay, some demon created that in order to knock out our faith. At some point, you just have to say, guys, how far are you going to go to try to hold that position? It's okay. Let's talk about it.
Well, Paul, we'll move into listener questions. I'll say for folks listening on the audio platforms, that's the end of part one. Unless you're on the paid feeds, you get it all in one go. Little bonus perk for you. But Paul, the book, Extraterrestrial Intelligence and the Catholic Faith, Are We Alone in the Universe with God and Angels? It's been available for some time. Is Amazon the best place to get it for folks? Or if you got a preference, I always like to ask.
Yeah. Well, you know what it is with Amazon? I mean, it's the easiest way to get it, but Amazon gets most of the income. But you can get it from tanbooks.com, tanbooks.com. That's the publisher. That's my preferred place. But that might not be, you know, if you're not in the United States, Amazon is probably easier. But yeah, you can get it from Amazon as well.
I always like to ask that after one, I can't remember who it was, but I guessed way back, mentioned that they weren't a big fan of Amazon and well, they appreciated, you know, it was the easiest place, like you say, for folks to get it and support local bookstores and small book. And yeah, I was like, yeah, absolutely. So I was like to ask now. And I'll ask just to finish off before we move into listening to questions, Paul, someone picks up a copy of the book, reads it. What do you want them to take away from it?
Wow. Yeah, I want to take away from it. First of all, if they're Christian, Catholic or any other form of Christian, to be able to look at this topic and say, if there is a disclosure, public disclosure of this, it doesn't have to overturn my faith. My faith can accommodate it. It has certain things like that in the past. There's room for it. There's still plenty of mystery. We have a lot of questions to answer. But that God is God. That's why I don't refer to any references to beings or entities. I always say creatures because that reminds us that they have a creator. It's God. And he created it and he has a purpose for them too. So to put it in that, so kind of don't panic. Just relax that. But also for at least a couple of centuries now, starting with people like Thomas Paine, who was the Englishman who wrote pamphlets in support of the American Revolution. Maybe some folks think he was a trader in the UK. I don't know. But anyway, he was widely read. He wrote a book called The Age of Reason, and he wrote extensively on this subject. He believed in ETI and made extensive claims that it would destroy the Christian faith once we discovered it. He's not the only one to say that. So to those folks, I would say, no, I don't think so. People may panic, people who don't understand their faith, people who don't have all the access to the traditions of their faith that are there, might panic. But if they take a deep breath, and read this book or read other things similar, it's not going to destroy their faith, it doesn't. So that would be the biggest thing. And then for other people just reading over their shoulders, that I'm hoping that as people start involved in this, have questions about consciousness, that's the topic these days. And along with that, survival after death, post-mortem survival, I would say, within the Western tradition for over 2000 years, if you've had an affirmation of what we, this kind of cosmic consciousness, you're talking about where the world came from. And for 2000 years, an affirmation that yes, the soul survives the body and there'll be a resurrection and then there's heaven and there's a hell. I would encourage you not just to rule that out, as if you somehow gotten past that, but to take another serious look at it. People are seriously looking at Hindu and Buddhist, other Eastern traditions to try to understand this. Don't rule this out. I found it convincing and I think others could too.
Thank you, Paul. We're going to go straight into listener questions in just a moment. If you've checked out part one, make sure you listen to part two. If you're not on any of the paid feeds, it will be out in a couple of days time. A lot of really interesting questions to come up. Stuff I've not touched on that folks might have wanted me to is going to come in here, and that way I can blame them for some of the awkward questions I'm going to have to ask you, Paul. But thank you very much if you've listened to part one, and look forward to seeing you all in part two. This is part two, Paul. Hi. So, Paul, first off, we'll go through some of the Patreon questions and then some of the YouTube viewers. Question first off from Steven Davies. Steven asks over on Patreon, what is your thoughts, Paul, on the Chris Bledsoe story, one of the most famous stories in ufology, UFOs, but also has quite a deep religious aspect to it?
Yes, I'm not as familiar with it as I should be. There's been so much to learn in the last couple of years. In fact, I will only live a few hours from there. I'm right near the North Carolina line of Georgia, so may even see if I could go visit there. I don't want to say too much without being too deep into it. I was just watching your podcast with Jeff Krpial, and some of the concerns y'all raised, I think are some of the concerns I have. I do think he's trying to fit his experience into, as Jeff said, a more conservative Christian experience. I'm not sure how well that works, especially talking about the lady. I would urge people not to associate that with the Virgin Mary, because of the things that this lady says. So mostly I just have to say, I can't take much of a position on it. I guess I'll stop with that.
Yeah, I'd be interested though, again, as someone like yourself would have to dive into because you wouldn't want the keynotes version of it. I think I could say you've got a guy here who had what sounds like an incredible experience, which then continued through himself and his family. There's a heavily religious aspect of this experience. And yeah, it wouldn't do it justice. So for me, definitely, I've interviewed Chris Bledsoe and Ryan Bledsoe. So even if you get a chance to listen to those, but lots of people have spoken to the Bledsoe's. Lovely people. Again, it's down to you what you believe. But from your point of view, I'd be very interested if you get the time to what you think of that particular story and experience and ongoing experience given what it is. But it would be very easy to dismiss it. But given the cast of characters, and I don't mean that in an offhanded way, that have been involved from various organizations and agencies, they're not just friends with lots of these people for bar mitzvahs and weddings and everything else in between. So, yeah, it's an interesting one. I'll leave it there as well, Paul, but I'd be interested to know your thoughts. From one Paul to another, Paul Eyre asks, of all the world's religions, including smaller indigenous people's beliefs, which one do you believe can most easily acknowledge a non-human intelligence? And which one do you think would struggle the most with the eventual and undeniable truth of the existence of a non-human intelligence? That's one of the ones I was glad I didn't have to ask you.
Yeah, I mean, I don't know that I would choose one. Among Western religions, I do think, you know, that the Catholic Church is not the only one to see this. Like, so Russ Goldthard said before that I think, at least at the upper levels of the Church, there's much more openness to it and willingness to accommodate if it's the truth. And I get that from, you know, emails and stuff I get from readers who are Catholic, astronomers, college professors, whatever. You would still have that segment that does not because they think it's all demons. Aside from that, I think, you know, Islam, as I understand it, already does have references in its sacred literature to life out there. So it shouldn't be, it shouldn't be much of a problem.
I've spoken with folks I work with who, again, have told me exactly the same thing, really open to the conversation.
Yep. The Mormon tradition, I talk about this in my book here, the Mormon tradition has references to life out of the planets. I would think, you know, Hinduism would be really open to it because they already have such a panoply of gods and they've been known traditionally for gods. They say, Oh, here, take this book, put your god on the shelf too. And I mean, in a good way, that they've been open to kind of bringing all that in. So I can't imagine they have too much trouble. The primal religions, the indigenous religions, I think probably in certain ways might be the most open. They have lots of traditions, but not usually a tradition of kind of highly articulated defined doctrine. So that they wouldn't have as much to fit it into. They would just have the cultural experience that talks about beings from the sky, often in that kind of thing and other spirits.
Let me ask you then Paul, because I think that is a difficult one to answer what one would struggle with it because so many religions seem to at least have a theme or variation of acknowledging something else out there or being possible. Is there any more generic element of religion across the board that would either be slightly contradicted by a non-human intelligence or may struggle the most? Are there any elements you can think of a populace, a general populace might struggle with if we find out we've got this non-human intelligence here?
Yeah, I would say whether the Christian tradition, there's a tradition actually highly influenced by the Enlightenment. That's very, once everything kind of very rational, we've worked out pretty logically. I won't mention specifics, but that don't leave a lot of room for mystery, and don't have a lot of humility when it comes to trying to understand the world, the parts that we don't understand. And I think that runs across several different denominations. And I think those are the folks that will have the, already have the hardest time without realizing if they imitate some scientists, not all, but some scientists in this attitude that you can't measure it and, you know, handle it with your hands, that kind of thing, then you got to reject it. I think what, I meant to say this in the early part of the broadcast that one of the things we do have to understand is that so many people, scientists and others, have rejected this whole thing because so much of it's based on witness testimony. And they say, you can't put it in a lab, you can't test it. It's not repeatable necessarily. So we can't really say much about that. And I've heard several scientists say that. But the truth is, you get outside of it. I think Jeff Krpial was kind of touching on this too. You get outside of that kind of scientific box, and you realize how much of what we know according to the testimony of witnesses. Almost the entire realm of history, you can't prove scientifically, you have documents and that kind of thing. And so you have to accept that, the testimony of witnesses. And there's certain standards and it's called historic art, either the art and science, you might say of writing history about what's more credible and what's not. And the same is true in most religions. So much of what we have is not something, you know, science, modern science wouldn't even around when it started, that we have a through witness testimony. The resurrection of Jesus Christ is something that's amazing, how many people saw the documents that documented. If we have to reject, if we say we can only know what we have according to human testimony, human first-person testimony, we got to give up most of what we know. But fourth century, so 16 years, 16 centuries ago, St. Augustine was making the same point in his book, The Confessions, this is autobiography, I'm writing a podcast commentary on it now. And he says, you know what, you know, people complain that we depend too much on authority, but think about how much you take on authority. How about places you've never been? How about things that happened in history? How about the circumstances of your birth and who your parents are? All of that really important information you take on the testimony of other people. So I just, you know, want to press back gently on people saying, well, all we've got is testimony. Because, yeah, that's really important. It's important to human life in general.
Yeah, people go their whole lives believing their parents are their parents. And then they turn 40 and just on a whim, they find out they were adopted or, you know, actually the father that raised them wasn't their biological father or something like that. And it's paradigm changing. But, you know, it doesn't mean it's not true. Just you believed one thing your whole life because of reason A. And then you find out something that changes that. So yeah, it's a really interesting point.
So anyway, I'm just saying, so we can't just reject out of hand, whether you're talking about religion or UFOs or anything else, history, anything else like that, that all we've got is witnesses, you know, especially when you're talking about thousands of them. That's not an adequate way of knowing certain things to say only by science.
The next question from David, you've kind of answered earlier, but I'm going to just give a little bit of a different spin on it. So what David asked was, how much credence does Paul give to the notion of pushback on extraterrestrial intelligence topic due to the idea that the really demonic force is out to deceive, and particularly in the US government, where there's a strong right-wing Christian element. And we talked about that Paul, you know, aspects of the US government. This is demonic. We don't want it out there. I wonder from your point of view and your unique point of view, in what way would a quote unquote demonic force or mischievous force or, you know, trickster force be trying to deceive us? Can you put that in your words? Because I think that's something I hear quite a lot, but I don't always know exactly what they mean.
Yeah, I mean, I didn't always exactly know what they mean either. It's apparently, I mean, I can't know this directly, but from folks like Willisondo and others have talked about it, that some of the folks in the military with a particularly, you know, particular Christian point of view, you could call it fundamentalist. I don't like to throw that word around too much, but that are convinced it's not the Bible. It's stuff that seems paranormal, therefore it's stamonic. It seems to be their argument in their case. Let's see, I'll make sure I get the question right. So you're saying...
Well, let me ask then, what other examples of what a demonic deception would be like in the Bible, for example, that I could try and relate to modern day. Why would whatever this is be trying to deceive us, or how would it be trying to deceive us, if that makes more sense?
Sure. Kind of two trains of thought, I think, on that. One is that because there are so many folks involved in UAP studies who have, so we sometimes... Exotic religious beliefs, maybe, I don't mean as a pejorative term, but I've taught courses on all kinds of things like that, that would contradict the faith they have, then they're making this leap of logic. You know, it's not logical at all. That, okay, since you have people involved in that, who believe in this, this must be demonic attempts to convince people to stop being Christian and embrace these other ideas. That's one. The other is a little more recent, but it's becoming a very vehement and vociferous group of folks who are saying, they're very involved with apocalyptic speculation, the end times, the end of the world. And they're saying, I think I mentioned this briefly, that the reason the government is doing all this and this deception is that they're trying to instill fear in us so that when finally the government says we need a one-world government that we'll all agree, sure, out of panic, that's the only way we're going to handle this demon, this alien invasion. And then that'll be set up for the Antichrist who rules the world and persecutes the church and represents the devil and acts on part of the devil. I mean, it's a very complicated mythology to me. It's superstitious almost, but those would be a couple of the reasons why people are, what kind of deception they think that is. That it's either going to lead up to any Christ who's going to persecute the church or you can't disconnect it from a lot of the other kinds of exotic religious police out there that reject the church.
Question from Fred. Fred asks, if angels and demons live in the spiritual realm, but our experiences is that angels or aliens are physical beings, how can folks argue that angels or aliens are demons? Does that make sense?
Yeah, what they're arguing, and again, I don't agree, but because I would say yes, if you find aliens have bodies, like the ones that people are claiming that they have, then that proves right there, they're not at least traditional Christian understanding of an angel or demon. They don't have bodies. But I think what they would be saying is that the aliens don't exist, and therefore whatever's happening is something that the demons are trying to pull over on us. So they appear in the sky, they have the abduction things where they appear as something else. They don't look like demons would normally look like, they look like aliens, whatever kinds of things, that it's all the demons trying to do that. So even with those those alien bodies, like I said, it's almost like the folks who didn't want to believe in the dinosaurs, that probably would go so far as to say, well, demons created that in order to trick us. I don't know if anybody said that yet about the bodies from Peru, but I wouldn't be surprised if someone starts saying that.
Is there any religious worry? And I think this goes back to the idea of religions collapsing, you know, if we had some kind of confirmation. If an extraterrestrial race, and this is quite an extreme question probably, Paul, but I'll probably have to ask it for my own sanity, I think, that if we found out there was an ultra terrestrial race and they confirmed, you know what, we are here, we've been here a long time, or another entity tells us they've been on this planet thousands of years before us, they've influenced us, they've been here, and they say that our idea of religion is all wrong, but it's largely based on their interference throughout the millennia. And would that change religions in general, do you think, or is it still the idea that that would be dismissed?
I think folks would say, well, aliens can get it wrong just as humans can. And just as if someone from another religion in the world came and talked to me and said, no, you got it all wrong, you Catholics, you Christians. It's this, it's this, and this. And I'd say, okay, let's talk about that. But it wouldn't just right away, oh no, he's got to be right. That's why, you know, the whole thing about genetic interference and stuff. And I hear that. And people say, you know, the big question this is raising is not who are they, but who are we really? Is there, you know, I think you've had probably one of the folks on your podcast before. He was told by folks in the intelligence community and classified cities or whatever, that they had been here and they had interfere with our genetics and that kind of thing. That's one where I would say, okay, I really need some data on that.
Well, on that one, Luella Zondo himself mentioned the idea that around 70,000 years ago, he mentioned, there was some sort of change in our genetics, where we got a bit of a boost to, yeah, a bit of a boost on.
So for that, I would say, okay, why go to aliens on that one? They're, the Christian teaching understanding is that, yeah, at some point, there was something that happened to whatever creatures were there that would have pressed them in the direction of what we are now, a special creation by God. There was a time when people would jokingly talk about the God of the gaps and what they meant was that, when science would discover something, and it's beginning to show that they thought God was not necessary for all this instead of thinking that that's just how God did it through natural processes. And there would be a gap in their knowledge or understanding. And some Christians would jump in and say, see, it was a miracle, see, it was a miracle. And they say, you're God of the gaps, just give us time to figure it out. I'm seeing the same thing happen with aliens. It's got the aliens of the gaps. So there seems to be some kind of boost genetically, that kind of thing. I just have to ask, why in the world would you go to aliens on that? There could be natural, very natural explanations. It could be that, in keeping with the Christian tradition that God intervened, even if it wasn't miraculous, but just did something to create what he was planning to create. So to me, that's not convincing evidence at all. It's evidence that something happened. But to attribute it to aliens, well, that wouldn't go there first.
I'm thinking of what you mentioned there, the Giorgio Succulis ancient aliens meme, when he does the aliens. So yeah, it's interesting. Fred asked a few questions. We've answered most of them, to be fair, within the body of the interviewer. So let's jump on to Peter. Peter Earnshaw, Ritz loves to send in a question. So thank you, Peter. The Catholic Church still conducts exorcisms and trains priests on how to exorcise demons from human hosts. Can Paul elaborate, and we touched on this earlier, but let's go into it, Paul. Can Paul elaborate on any relationship between extraterrestrial slash non-human intelligence and demonic possession? Where do you sit on that one?
Yeah, I mean, it's part of what I was saying before that I think, first of all, I think that what we're encountering out there is a whole bunch of different things, some of which we don't understand at all, some maybe a little, and that there is, there are in some cases, there seems to be, to me, as someone who's familiar with the exorcism process, that kind of thing, and classical cases of demonic possession and oppression, sure seems to me to be some cases that fit the demonic profile, you might say. So, some of the abduction experiences where the creatures are malevolent, where they injure the person, where they take them against their will and bring them back. Now, I'm not saying every account like that is to my, but I'm saying I could see how you can interpret some of those in that way, sure seems to fit the profile. I think it was, I don't know if I want to say his name, I may be getting wrong, but I think it was James Lakatsky who was talking recently, I think on the Weaponized Podcast, about experiences having to do with Skinwalker Ranch. And first of all, I want to say that the Catholic Church, Catholic teaching takes very seriously the notion of a curse, that it opens a door for demonic activity, and you don't have to be a Catholic to do the curse. And so in Skinwalker's history, there is the tradition that one Native American tribe cursed another one and that's somehow connected to this. And to me, that seems quite possible. Some of the things that go on there sure seem to fit the profile, but the one that clearest was clearest to me. And I sure hope I'm not misquoted, but as I recall, Dr. Lakatsky said that at some point something came on him, he kind of froze and it began speaking through him. That's about as classic a description of demonic possession as you can get. Maybe it wasn't, maybe it wasn't demonic possession, but I can see why some people think, okay, it's that, but what I keep saying to them is you can't say it's all that. There are too many things out there, and so many things don't fit that profile at all. Those cubes or the spheres inside of them that the Navy pilot saw, you're going to say, what does that got to do with the answer? Anything like that. So some overlap, but I'd say most of it just seems to be something else altogether.
Skinwalker Ranch, there's a lot of that, and the Hitchhiker Effect very much, you could say that as Poltergeist type activity. Thomas Winterton talked about events happening at his family home with his wife and child. George Knapp said the same thing that he and his wife both had Hitchhiker Effect. Again, you can replace a lot of what that sounds like is happening to be Poltergeist type activity, going off the classic movies or descriptions, whatever that might look like. Again, as we've mentioned, Paul labels one thing, you know, one man's X and another man's B, you know, there you go, it's the same type of thing. Another question from Peter. Now he touches on something we mentioned earlier, but I just wonder if you can expand on your thoughts on the last part of it. So he mentions David Grush talking about the Italian crash in the 1930s, Mussolini government collapses, and then apparently the Pope gets involved with the US, and they moved that object out of there. But he asks, do you think, for example, as the President of the United States would get briefed on the UFO phenomenon, it's just as likely the Pope would get similar briefings to this day?
I think so. I mean, I really do. As others have pointed out, for a long time, the Vatican has had its own kind of information network, if you want to call it that, Surveillus, whatever, worldwide, and there are lots of things in the archives. They've had information coming to them for a long time about all kinds of things, and this kind of information, because to many it resembles some spiritual stuff going on, it would make all kinds of sense that if somebody experienced that, say, wherever you're in Africa or Italy or wherever, that they would go and talk to the priest about it, and then the priest might talk to the bishop, and it would just go on up the chain. There might even be a word out at some point that if you have experience like this, we want to know about it. I'm not saying I know that for sure, of course I can't. But I do think it would make sense that the Vatican would be interested in these things, might even collect stuff about it in the archives. It would just be a natural interest for them, and it would be natural for people to report it. I mean, I've talked to others who said, yeah, I had an experience, and first thing I did is went to my priest and say, how do I figure this out, and how does it get in with my faith? So they're going to talk about it to spiritual leaders, and those leaders are, I think, eventually going to be talking about it on Up to Chain.
Again, it makes sense, as you say, the president right now, Joe Biden, is talking to three or 400, 500 million Americans on whatever he's talking about, but that message is relevant to X amount of Christians, or folks to Catholic faith in the United States, that is relevant to folks around the world of that same religion. So if he's the head of a religion of 1.4 billion people, then of course that's someone who's going to relay that message as is any other kind of spiritual leader like that. So that makes sense. A question from Steve. Steve says, the Catholic Church has already put thought into aliens and non-human intelligence throughout the centuries. Though the Catholic Church goes to great lengths to inculcate beliefs and dogma. He says to the, is it laity? L-A-I-T-Y. Is that laity?
Laity.
Yeah, laity. I've never heard that word before. Sorry, Steve. So beliefs and dogma to the laity. They are still often remains a disconnect. Lay understanding of the faith, understanding as imperfect. Regardless of what theologians, priests, and church authorities have said about non-human intelligences, it may still be a large undertaking to communicate this to the worldwide laity. I'm guessing that just means populous. What does Paul have to say about this?
Yeah, laity just means people who are not ordained. So we're not priests, deacons, bishops. So if I understand the question, you say, how might the church...
So it's still a large undertaking. Regardless of what theologians, priests, and church authorities have said about ET, it still may be a large undertaking to communicate this to the worldwide laity. What does Paul have to say about this?
Yeah, I would say, again, you have a lot of people who just aren't interested. They're going about their daily lives and they tell me this all the time. You have other folks who are interested and may be willing to read a book like mine. And so I'd encourage them to do that. It's because it just brings together, you know, 400 pages, very careful documentation of the tradition of all this and what theologians have thought and then how I would present all these things. But for a lot of them, it's probably, it's just going to have to happen by some kind of public disclosure that they respond to. Because I really, I don't think, I could be wrong, but I don't think that the Catholic Church in particular will be the one to get out in front and say, okay, we've known this much. They're probably going to wait for one or more of the secular governments to say something first. So in the popular culture, books like mine could help. There's some documentaries probably being made, might help. But in the end, a lot of folks are going to need something more than that to have their minds opened.
A good podcast with a Scottish host, that'll help.
Of course.
No, God help them. God with a small G. So a good question to follow on from, actually, I think, and this goes on to the YouTube questions. Now, question from Peter says, funnily enough, I've been thinking about what if it's the Vatican itself that makes the first move with disclosure? It would take it out of the hands of partisan governments, but could upset some other religions or belief systems. On the other hand, it would placate the Christian elements and the American government. He thinks it would be the best solution. What are your thoughts on that, Paul?
Well, I'd love to see that, personally. At this point, I've said before, I'd just be thrilled with the Vatican making a statement in response to the kind of things that people are throwing at me. The Catholic Church doesn't take a position on it because so much of what they say about the demons, they build it on their conclusion that it's contrary to Catholic teaching. It's not. So I would be happy with that just so that those people would stop saying that. It's not contrary to Catholic teaching. More than that, I would love to hear the Church say, we haven't said anything officially about it, but it is possible. That would be great. But for me, the best of all, if it's true and if they know, would be for them to some degree or another, take the leap and say, yes, this is it and we've got a lot to learn about. That would be great. I'm sure whoever knows if they do know, just like our government, they have the reasons for thinking it's not time yet or that somebody else needs to do it. But that's just my personal opinion. I'd love to see them make some statement, take the lead on that.
That would be very interesting, be a great movie or a TV show at least. I see that scenario being quite unlikely still. I just couldn't see it not being one of the superpowers, China, Russia, US, obviously being the lead one.
Or even one of the developing nations, sorry. Even one of the developing nations, Brazil finally, or Mexico, one of those finally came out and said, yeah, we got all this stuff and the Americans wouldn't let us talk about it, but we're going to anyway, finally.
I mean, some folks would argue, and God, I don't know if I want to bring this up, that they tried that recently in Peru with the Peruvian mummies in the Mexican Congress. Yeah, I can get Jaime Musan on the podcast to talk about that. Just given how ill I've been for the last few weeks, it's not been one I've wanted to look at too much. But if folks would like to hear that in the new year, give me a shout and I can look at arranging that because that's an interesting conversation. It would be respectful, of course, but is there still an element of if it is that smaller? That was my point, Paul, that imagine those Peruvian mummies were or are genuine. Okay. Is there a PR disaster waiting to happen with it being done in the wrong way? In the sense that people will just dismiss it, or it could go badly, and that's why it has to be handled by the church or the head of state for the US, Russia, China.
It could be, but those latter folks are sure taking their time. I mean, they've got so many, especially the US government, so many factions there that don't want this to come out at all.
Yeah. And I think even if and when it does, and I'm sure we're going to get some more information in the coming months, maybe not full capital D disclosure, but we'll get something. I think just given what we've gone through in the last three years with COVID pandemic and all that stuff, there's still going to be huge elements of.
So, you know, America, that confidence, trust in the US government, or in government in general, in the United States, is just about at its lowest point ever. And that's, and not just government authorities, but other medical authorities after the whole COVID thing, political authorities, all kinds of authorities. So, yeah, I think there are a lot of folks who would just say, yeah, they, you know, they, I mean, actually, I had a friend tell me that another friend, I won't mention who it was, when he heard about my book, he... We had said, yes, aliens brought to you by the same people who brought you the COVID pandemic. And what do you think about COVID? Do you think, okay, I get their thinking, they felt betrayed by the government, they felt misled by the government. And so they think that's just another case of that. There's a lot of that to this.
That was the meme during COVID, wasn't it? That up next is aliens. And I think that went worldwide everywhere. It was there behind the curtain ready to come out. So anyway, this is not a COVID podcast or political broadcast by any means, as I get accused of sometimes, even though I hate all politics and anything like that. So yeah, not for me, but yeah, that's it. I'm Scottish. I hate everyone equally. So that's the best way to be. So question from Patricia says, thank you very much, Andy, for your work. Oh, I never read that. I don't know why I did. Sorry, I hate praising myself. Oh, God, no, no. That's why I go into my wife, Nick. She'll soon get that out of me.
They're good at that.
Yeah. My question to your guest is, his opinion on the supposed stigmata the Catholic institution declared St. Francis of a CC received, compared to what in reality seems to have happened to him. And that is a close encounter with orbs that as a result made him ill. This was declared by Chris Bledsoe as well as Dr. Diana Pasulka. These declarations seem to have been given to them from the Vatican itself. What are your thoughts on that?
Oh, well, again, I don't want to try to view everything in the Catholic tradition through the UAP lens. I don't think that's a good way to approach it. Yeah, there were all kinds of amazing phenomena going on when he received the stigmata. But apparently he and the people around him and the Church ever since had a particular understanding of, yeah, that it's unusual, but that through the administration of an angel, God was giving him the stigmata. We don't need to go looking for UFOs or something else there. It's, let me say this, people say, we even touched on this. They'll say, well, in the Book of Ezekiel, the Prophet Ezekiel, you have this thing out there that looks mechanical, it's wheels within wheels, and it's got eyes and wings and stuff. So that's got to be a UFO, right? Well, let's step back from that. What if one of the things most of us in this conversation agree on today, is that you can't automatically dismiss witness testimony that they've been abducted, right? That what often happens is when they try to tell somebody, the person they tell doesn't believe in UFOs or aliens, but they do believe in something else. So they'll reinterpret as that. So they believe in hallucination or mental illness, or they see something land. They say, well, I don't believe any of that, but I do believe in swampcasts and Venus. And so whatever they thought it was, it was actually this. So they dismiss what that person thought because they don't believe in the things that person thought, and they put their own beliefs as substitutes. I don't think, I think it's the same thing with classic passages like Ezekiel. It's really disrespectful to the folks who recorded the vision and the tradition that handled it and brought it down. Because for Ezekiel and for the readers of the book, it was not unidentified at all. It was a likeness of the glory of God coming down on a throne. So I don't think we should go there first and say, well, what really happened was it was a UFO because I don't believe in God, I don't believe in angels, but I do believe in UFOs. So that's what it must be. You have to look at the context, you have to look at the person who had the experience. So anyway, I think it's the same way with experiences of Fatima, the apparition of the Virgin Mary in Portugal in the early 1900s. I think it's the same case with St. Francis. I don't think it's wise to go look at that and say, oh, well, that somehow resembles UAP stuff today, so that's got to be what it is when the context itself demands something different.
I spoke to a gentleman and I can't remember who it was, or the name of the organization. So please reach out again if you still listen to the podcast. Last year, I think it was in the summer, he worked at an institute, something to do with religion, that's how bad my memory is. And he had a big interest in the UFO topic, was writing an article about that and religion. I think it was an educational type of institute. And he brought up within the conversation back and forward with me, that he didn't believe the Ezekiel's Wheel experience was anything to do with UFOs. And he told me why at the time, and I can't remember, so please reach out to me. But interesting you bring that up, Paul, because he had the same thought that as much as there are things he believed within the Bible that reference potential UFO events, if you want to call them that, he didn't think Ezekiel's Wheel was one, and people were looking too much into that as being that sort of event. So that was just interesting you brought that one up. Final question then from Strange Fractal. And this I think is a nice way to kind of sum things up, Paul. As you've mentioned this in a couple of different ways, but what kind of statements might you make to religious communities to encourage them to embrace disclosure through the lens of their perspective spiritual teachings?
Yeah, I mean, this part of what I talked about at the Soul Symposium, that first of all, that we need to give ourselves to studying the evidence that's out there. A lot of the folks who will say to me, it's all demons or whatever, I say, well, have you actually read anything like, you know, In Plain Sight by Roscoe Dard? Have you read any of these other books or things where you look at serious research into it, journalistic and otherwise, or you look at the scientific evidence or the, you know, some of the sightings with all the different sensing materials to you. You need to give some kind of weight to all of that. And they'll always say, no, I don't know any of that I want to read about. So the first thing I would say is folks, you need to, whatever your religious tradition, you need to pay more attention to the amazing amount of cumulative evidence that we have of things going on out there, that they're real. Second, that I would encourage you to look with, within your tradition, as I encourage Catholics to do, and even non-Catholics to look into the Catholic tradition, to see that this conversation has been going on, and that we have all kinds of things that make room for this, so that it's not contrary. I've been accused of teaching contrary to the tradition, the Catholic tradition, when actually I'm recovering things from the tradition that other folks have, many other folks have lost. Another thing I say is that this world that God has given us is very full of mystery. It's bigger than we can imagine. It's more complex, nuanced, and that often for religious people, there's a failure of imagination, I would call it, where their imagination isn't up to the task of encountering all the mystery and the amazing complexity of what God has in fact given us. So they need to begin to stretch their imaginations and to see that they can't always connect the dots the way they always have. Then finally, I encourage them, especially Christians, but I think it would be the case in other traditions as well, that to maintain a sense of humility, a sense of wonder, and I define wonder as humility in the face of mystery. Certainly, that's part of the Catholic tradition. I think it should be part of all religious traditions. Recognizing that there are mysteries we don't understand yet. We don't have it all, even if we feel sure that we have certain parts of the puzzle, there's always stuff that we don't have yet. And for Christians and for Jews also, I would say, go back and look at the book of Job. Look at the God that Job worshiped, and that we say we worship too. And that when he was making complaints about how things were and that kind of thing, God answered him out of the world and then said, Job, where were you when I laid the foundations of the world? Where were you when I created everything? Where were you when I threw the stars out there and all these other things that are right in the Pleiades? Do you understand any of that? Do you know the ordinances, the laws, so to speak, of the heavens? And Job realizes, oh my gosh, I've been presumptuous about all this, and he falls on his face and says, I don't know what to do. That we need that kind of remembrance that, you know, that God is, he's creator, he's God, he can do what he wants. And I mean, whatever, keeping with his character, whatever is not inherently impossible. So let's be humble about this. Don't think we've got it all figured out. So I'd say all of those things probably for any religious tradition to keep in mind.
And I think that's good advice for anyone who even just has involved in the UFO topic. I think in the UFO topic, everyone has their own, you know, metaphorical church they worship at or their own belief systems, their own figures they look to. Some of them borderline on worship of certain individuals across the board. But I think you're right that you have to just be, you know, sensible, logical, be respectful of other people's beliefs and try not to put all your eggs in one basket, or you end up with kind of egg in your face potentially. But yeah, I think there's a lot of different conversations happening out there and especially, like I say, in the UFO topic where we don't have the answers. And we're all kind of looking to those, like you said, with religion at the start, Paul, we're all kind of looking at those same questions and asking the same questions just in different ways, aren't we?
We aren't. Even science is that way. I mean, I'm a professional historian, historical theology is my field. And so I look at especially the history of Christian faith, but I've also looked at the history of science. And one of the things you find, Thomas Queen and the nature of scientific revolutions that you do get these paradigm shifts in science history, that it's also possible for scientists to become dogmatic about certain things. People like Avi Loeb and others are running into that, where if we don't talk about it, we know exactly what's possible, what's not. The scientists also have to have some humility about this and to realize, I mean, look at things like quantum theory. Oh my goodness, that's the kind of cutting-edge physics, the possibilities that opens up. We have to be humble about that. We say, no, we don't have it all figured out. Tell me what you're thinking.
Absolutely, Paul, it has been wonderful speaking with you, and definitely have to get you back on next year, and the new year as well. Is your foray into the UFO world finished now with the book, or is there more to come from you?
Well, that depends on what happens. I mean, I'd love to do a revised edition of the book now. It's been two years and so much has happened in the conversation since then. I've even discovered historical documents that I didn't know were there before that would add to the conversation. I think I'm going to be writing an article for a science journal soon, a science and religion journal. I'm going to probably be writing some articles about it. But a lot depends on what groups like this whole foundation does, if they want to continue to open up the conversation about UFO and religion. And just so much could happen. What if we had a public disclosure this year? I think I'd be talking to a lot of people, probably having people. People want me to come talk.
Hi everyone, Andy here. This is a special announcement for folks who listen to the show via Spotify. You can now support the pod directly through Spotify for less than the price of a coffee each month. Giving you ad-free content, no sponsorships, early access and bonus shows as well. So many of you have chosen to support the show through Patreon and Apple Premium, and I appreciate this has been a long time coming for Spotify listeners. Just search That UFO Podcast Premium in Spotify, or click the link in this description for this announcement. Otherwise, Apple Premium is still available with a two-week free trial as well, again, from less than the price of a coffee, or you can sign up for Patreon for the additional benefits that come with those tiers. Again, thank you to everyone who supports the podcast and just listens to the shows. Lots of great content to come.